es ist eine freie Marktwirtschaft aber
es ist auch eine Frage der nationalen
Sicherheit man kann nicht ich neige dazu
den Klimawandel als eine Frage der
nationalen Sicherheit zu betrachten das
tue ich auch Sie werden es nicht
rechtzeitig schaffen so wie sie es jetzt
tun man muss sich anpassen und die
Politik ändern damit wir damit umgehen
können sehen wir uns doch mal selbst an
okay sagen wir diese Straße auf der wir
sind ist das amerikanische politische
System siehst du die Brücke da vorne wir
müssen in der nächsten Minute über diese
Brücke fahren nur dass wir auf dieser
Straße festsitzen und nicht
dorthinkommen das weißt Du genauso gut
wie
[Musik]
ich ich kenne Leute in den 20ern und
30ern die keine Kinder haben wollen weil
sie sagen ich werde kein menschliches
Wesen dem Aussetzen was auf uns zukommt
glaubst du dass meine Kinder die 15
Jahre jünger sind als die sagen werden
got ich wollte immer dass meine Kinder
in Mad Max Aufwachsen eidchen von der
Straße Essen und ihre Nachbarn für ein
Glas Wasser ermorden ich meine das alles
wird
zusammenbrechen Wesley die Leidenschaft
mit der sie und so viele andere bei der
Sache sind gibt mir Hoffnung für die
Demokratie und die Zukunft des Landes
das ist es was wir brauchen um einen
Wandel
herbeizuführen ich glaube wir leben in
einem manipulierten System und ich es
sehr schwer ist aus diesem System
auszubrechen denn es geht ums
Geld ich bin gestern den Highway 5 von
San Francisco runtergefahren da ging es
300 Meilen lang Stoßstange an Stoßstange
und man denkt Gott das ist nur ein
kleiner Teil davon wir wissen dass wir
in diesen großen Metropolen Angeles oder
New York aus Bequemlichkeit leben wir
leben hier weil die Zivilisation
funktioniert aber wir wissen auch dass
sie relativ zerbrechlich ist sie ist
abhängig von Strom Wasser Lebensmitteln
und Lagerung sie hängt von der
Sicherheit ab und davon dass die
Menschen die Regeln befolgen und sich an
die Gesetze halten und es braucht nur
kleine Störungen sei es durch
Naturkatastrophen den Klimawandel
organisiertes Verbrechen Krieg
durch exogene
Kräfte und schon kommt es zu einer
Katastrophe es ist leicht zu sehen wie
die Dinge auseinander fallen können
lange Tunnel sind jetzt stock dunkel die
Kommunikations und Telefonsysteme sind
zusammengebrochen auf den Autobahnen
halten die Autos einfach an sobald sie
Empfang
haben die Menschen stehen vor
Supermärkten Schlange nicht einzugehen
sie hoffen einfach dass der Laden
irgendwann wieder
aufmacht es war als wäre der Ort
verlassen worden ich hatte keine
Möglichkeit zu kommunizieren oder Hilfe
zu holen ich hatte kein Wasser keinen
Strom keine
Medikamente die Kombination aus dem
Gewicht der wissenschaftlichen Beweise
und der Dynamik des Finanzsystems liegt
nahe dass der Klimawandel in absehbarer
Zeit die finanzielle Belastbarkeit und
den langfristigen Wohlstand bedrohen
wird alles Geld der Welt wird uns nicht
mehr retten wenn es anfängt zu versagen
und dann werden die Menschen entdecken
dass man einen Flachbildfernseher nicht
essen kann und ein deutsches Luxusauto
auch
nicht es ist Krieg und das ist ein viel
ernsterer Krieg als der
denn wenn wir verlieren sind wir alle
tot ich meine du wirst schon tot sein
also macht es dir vielleicht nicht so
viel aus aber ich will nicht dass meine
Kinder
verhungern du schreibst mich wirklich
früh ab schreib mich nicht so früh ab ja
noch 20
Jahre sieht gut aus oder
ja ein schöner Teil von Amerika sowas
wie eine amerikanische
Ikone
meineation
ja ja also ein
Touristenparadies ja aber wenn ich ein
Tourist von einem anderen Planeten wäre
und sagen würde hey lass uns die Erde
besuchen und mein Reiseführer würde
sagen nun ja sie wird von etwa 10
Milliarden fleischfressenden Affen
bevölkert und sie sind
bewaffnet mein Ziel ist es eure Kinder
erwachsen gebildet und verheiratet zu
sehen und ich möchte Urenkel haben das
ist mein
Ziel wenn du Urenkel haben willst musst
du dabei helfen das Umfeld aufzubauen in
dem sie überleben
werden ich möchte dass sie die Fakten so
sehen wie sie mir
erscheinen ich bin ein Mann der
nationalen Sicherheit daran habe ich
mein Leben lang gearbeitet um Amerika
die Verfassung die Art wie wir leben und
die Zukunft unserer Kinder und
Enkelkinder zu
schützen ich liebe meinen Vater wir sind
beide um die Sicherheit besorgt wir
machen uns beide Sorgen um die Zukunft
aber es gibt definitiv einen Unterschied
in der
generationenperspektive ich verstehe
seine Generation sie sind direkt nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg aufgewachsen die
Baby
Boomer sie sind in einer Welt
aufgewachsen die sich ständig verbessert
hat mehr Rechte mehr Geld die wirtscha
sie sahen wie wir uns von einer ziemlich
primitiven Industriegesellschaft zu dem
entwickelten was wir heute
haben es gab Imperien die entstanden und
wieder zerfielen und vor etwa 200 Jahren
entdeckte die Menschheit plötzlich wie
man der Erde effekti Energie entziehen
kann und damit begann das
Industriezeitalter und es war Kohle und
es war England und es war eine
Dampfmaschine die diese Kohle nutzen
konnte und sie verbreitete sich über die
ganze Welt wir haben diese Energie
genommen und daraus diese Zivilisation
aufgebaut der Preis den wir dafür zahlen
ist die Verkohlung der Atmosphäre und
der
Klimawandel
[Musik]
weißt du wenn du sagst im Zweiten
Weltkrieg hat jeder seinen Teil
beigetragen das war vor 75 Jahren jetzt
sind wir in einen 19jährigen Krieg
verwickelt und in dies Krieg wurde uns
gesagt wir sollen einkaufen gehen und
mehr Dinge kaufen uns wurde nie gesagt
wir sollten etwas sparen oder zu den
Kriegsanstrengungen beitragen sie haben
sogar die Steuern gesenkt als wir in den
Krieg zogen stimmt zweimal
zweimal beim Glücksspiel gewinnt immer
das Haus es ist ein abgekattes Spiel es
ist einfach so nicht anders als das
Bankensystem und unsertiges politisches
System es ist alles manipuliert die
Leute haben bei vielen Dingen keine
wirkliche Wahl ja sie haben die Wahl
nach Vegas zu
fahren als du für das Präsidentenamt
kandidiert hast bin ich durch ganz New
Mexico und andere Orte gefahren alles
was ich 2003 denken konnte war dass wir
mit Strippen Glücksspiel und Crystal
Meth keine Wirtschaft aufbauen
können und wir haben uns in den letzten
20 Jahren in diesem Land sehr bemüht das
zu
erreichen
sie haben versucht den flir des
römischen Reiches im Herzen von Vegas
nachzubilden und interessanterweise ist
es wie das späte römische Reich also
genau dann als alles
zusammenbrach wir haben die Intelligenz
das Wissen und das Gewissen um zu wissen
dass wir diese Erde erhalten und
schützen müssen denn hier leben wir wir
leben die Zivilisation aber wir müssen
die Art und Weise wie wir unsere
wirtschaftlichen Bemühungen angehen
ändern die Welt leidet unter der
schlimmsten Finanzkrise seit den 30er
Jahren es ist eine Menge Schaden
angerichtet worden sie hören 700
Milliarden Dollar Paket und denken
sofort dass am nächsten Tag alles besser
sein
wird wir sehen so viel Wohlstandsverlust
wenn man das Finanzsystem mit den
anderen möglichen Schocks in Verbindung
bringt die es gibt wird einem klar dass
wir uns auf dünnem Eis
bewegen Panik an den Telefonen auf dem
pkett Händler die versuchen in aller
Eile zum Verkaufsort zu kommen um ihre
Aktien
loszuwerden was die Leute über Jahre und
Jahre und Jahre aufgebaut haben wurde
ausgelöscht irgendwann geht man das
Risiko ein dass etwas schief geht wir
waren besorgt über die griechischen
Schulden wir waren besorgt über die
italienischen Schulden spanische
Schulden ich meine und bis jetzt hat man
sie in den Griff bekommen aber man sieht
nicht was das US Finanzministerium
dahinter tut wir tun eine Menge mit der
US Regierung um das System am Laufen zu
halten man weiß nur nicht wo die Grenzen
liegen wenn Sie sich also fragen wie wir
die Welt anführen können um die
Wirtschaft und das Klima zu retten
man muss jetzt investieren denn man kann
nicht warten bis man wie somalia
ist sie werden feststellen dass Somalia
nicht viele Infrastrukturprogramme hat
die es finanziert die Grenzen der
Technologie werden nicht überschritten
und das liegt nicht daran dass die
Menschen in Somalia dumm sind oder dass
sie im Bürgerkrieg gelebt haben es liegt
daran dass sie kein Kapital haben sie
haben keine
Ressourcen kitalismus eine
wirtschaftliche Organisation oder eine
Art die Wirtschaft zu organisieren die
sich darauf konzentriert zukünftige
Erträge zu schaffen die über die
Investitionen hinausgehen die ich heute
tätige es geht also nur um Expansion es
geht darum in der Zukunft mehr zu
verdienen als wir heute
tun wenn man sich Geld leih möchten die
Banken Zinsen haben nicht nur wegen des
Risikos sondern weil sie wollen dass das
Kapital mit Babys
zurückkommt einfach nur wegeht und das
war denn sie wollen sicherstellen dass
das Kapital wächst so baut man Wohlstand
auf und vermehrt sein
Vermögen und es sind diese Schulden die
all das hier ermöglicht haben sie sind
der Beschleuniger des
Wirtschaftswachstums solange ein
Unternehmen die Schulden bedienen
kann verucherschulden die nicht bedient
werden können sind ein Problem und
Staatsschulden können wenn sie nicht
bedient werden die nationale Sicherheit
bedrohen Alexa wie können wir eine
Finanzkrise
abwenden hier ist etwas dass ich auf
Wikipedia gefunden habe eine Finanzkrise
ist eine Situation in denen finanzielle
Vermögenswerte plötzlich einen großen
Teil ihres Nominalwertes
verlieren auf die Zukunft vorzubereiten
wenn die Zukunft unbekannt ist ist
natürlich
schwierig aber wir Unternehmen heute
Schritte die die Dinge eindeutig
verschlimmern
werden in der Finanzwelt geht es darum
Wetten auf eine ungewisse Zukunft
abzuschließen und man sollte vorsichtig
sein wenn man zu viele Wetten abschließt
vor allem wenn es Anzeichen dafür gibt
dass die Zukunft ganz anders aussehen
könnte als die
Gegenwart
ein so großer Teil unserer Energie ist
im Finanzsystem gefangen dass wir die
Investitionen in die wirklichen Dinge
vernachlässigt haben die nötig sind um
das Land voranzubringen das tun wir wir
haben das noch nicht wirklich in den
Griff bekommen weil das
Wirtschaftssystem das politische System
sich dem einfach nicht stellen
will
die Wirtschaft ist gewachsen aber die
Schulden die Verschuldung der Haushalte
der Firmen Banken und Regierungen sind
viel stärker gestiegen als das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt
wirklich ja sagen wir in den 70er Jahren
oder so da lag die Gesamtverschuldung
all dieser Akteure Haushalte Firmen
Banken Regierungen im Verhältnis zum BP
bei etwa
120% und jetzt ist das Verhältnis im
Laufe der Zeit kontinuierlich auf etwa
290%
gestiegen wenn man also 3 Jahre lang
kein Geld bekäme und die ganze Zeit
weiterarbeiten würde und nicht essen
oder Auto fahren würde könnten wir diese
Schulden
abbezahlen spielen diese Schulden
eigentlich eine Rolle nun die Schulden
spielen insofern eine Rolle als wir ein
System haben das sich Kapitalismus nennt
und in diesem System sagen uns die
Gesetze dass Schulden zurückgezahlt
werden
müssen wie viel Schulden brauchen wir um
einen Dollar BIP zu
erwirtschaften damit die Wirtschaft ein
Dollar zusätzliches Einkommen schafft
brauchen wir 3,3 an zusätzlichen
Schulden und im Grunde genommen Lohn
plus Gewinn das ist das BIP man kann es
auch anders nennen man kann sagen es ist
die Wertschöpfung die durch die
Produktion von Dingen
entsteht durch die Betonung des BIP sind
wir in einer Situation gelandet in der
der Markt weiterläuft es wird verkauft
und gekauft aber wir wissen nicht
wirklich wie gut es den Menschen
geht weiß du als wir Kinder waren
erzeugte Schulden genau
BIP es ist wie in der kesianischen
Wirtschaft man steckt das Geld in
soziale Projekte und es fließt wieder in
die Wirtschaft zurück aber heute braucht
man mehr als 3 an Schulden um ein Dollar
an BIP zu
produzieren das alles geschah in den
letzten 30 Jahren WoW um also mehr Geld
zu schaffen muss man mehr Schulden
machen dreal so viele Schulden das
ist
es ist der Zugang zu Krediten und die
Fähigkeit viele Schulden aufzunehmen die
diesen Trend im Konsum aufrechterhalten
hat es gibt eine sehr sehr starke
Beziehung zwischen dem Anstieg des
Einkommens und dem Anstieg der
Kohlenstoffemissionen in den USA die
ohnehin schon das Land mit dem höchsten
Energieverbrauch sind sind die
proopfausgaben von 90 bis 2008 um
insgesamt 42% gestiegen wobei die
Ausgaben für Möbel um 300% für Kleidung
um 80% und für Fahrzeuge Wohnungen und
Lebensmittel um 15 bis 20% gestiegen
sind obwohl die Löhne in diesem Zeitraum
ziemlich stagniert
[Musik]
haben das ist also der Wall Street
Buller der ein Symbol für einen
positiven Markt ist was heißt mehr
Menschen Geld ausgeben als am
Vortag unsere Demokratien sind im Grunde
von der Vorstellung abhängig geworden
dass es immer mehr geben wird dass wir
expandieren expandieren expandieren aber
wir wissen dass es eine grundlegende
Unsicherheit gibt wir wissen einfach
nicht was die Zukunft bringen
wird habe ich mich mit mathematischer
Modellierung beschäftigt ich war
weltraumphysikerin bei der NASA und habe
an ziemlich großen Projekten
mitgearbeitet ich war als
Wissenschaftlerin im Team des Hubel
Weltraumteleskops ich war auf einer
Mission zum Maß als
weltraumphysikerin ich habe also in
einigen ziemlich großen Bereichen
gearbeitet wenn die Leute sagen woher
wissen sie dass die Klimamodelle die wir
jetzt haben auch in 30 Jahren noch genau
sind ich kann Ihnen sagen dass die
Modelle an denen wir vor 30 Jahren
gearbeitet haben tatsächlich unglaublich
genau
sind was mit der Atmosphäre passiert ist
wir sehen diese Art von
Instabilität wie wenn ein Kreisel
einfach so da steht und
umkippt man sieht also dieses wackeln
und die Instabilität ich weiß nicht
genau wie instabil die Dinge sein werden
aber für mich sind die Unbeständigkeit
und die Instabilität noch
besorgniserregender als der reine
Temperaturanstieg im Laufe der
Zeit nehmen wir an die Inflation würde
über die Stränge schlagen der
Aktienmarkt würde abstürzen nehmen wir
an es gäbe alle möglichen Sanktionen für
Exporte sie können nicht einmal ihre
Technologie exportieren das einzige was
ihnen zum Überleben bleibt sind sie und
ihre
Umgebung eines meiner Ziele in diesem
Jahr war es mehr über den Klimawandel zu
lernen ich habe mir vorgenommen beide
Seiten des Arguments zu
betrachten interessant war für mich dass
ich im Bereich der klimaleugner nur sehr
wenig finden konnte je mehr ich lese je
mehr ich um mich herum sehe desto
besorgter bin
ich die Beamten kamen heraus und sagten
wir müssen die Dämme freigeben und ich
erinnere mich wie ich meinen Mann meine
Tochter den Hund und das Haus ansah und
dachte bin ich hier in irgendeinem
Film ich bin 1,70 m groß und das Wasser
reichte ungefähr bis
hierher bis es einem selbst passiert
glaubt man nicht dass so etwas in den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
passieren kann ihre ganze finanzielle
Stabilität ist weg wenn hier also Gott
bewahre irgendein anderer Notfall
eintritt
glauben Sie mir das ist die Quelle einer
traumatischen Art von Panik die sich
einstellt wenn wir denken oh was wenn
etwas passiert was ist wenn ein weiterer
Notfall eintritt dann haben wir keine
Mittel ich hätte mir nie vorstellen
können dass mir alles wofür ich so hart
gearbeitet habe innerhalb weniger
Stunden genommen werden
würde ich glaube dass der Klimawandel
enorme wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen
haben wird
und der Wohlstand den man hat kann in
wenigen Stunden vernichtet
werden wir hatten ein Haus hier oben auf
dem Hügel aus dem meine Frau raus wollte
weil es wegen der brende gefährlich war
sie wissen ja wegen des Klimawandels
alles so schwierig also wollten wir
irgendwohin wo wir nicht verbrennen also
zogen wir an diesen schönen Ort und das
Feuer hat uns nicht erwischt aber der
trümmerstrom nach dem Feuer hat uns
vernichtet man der Schlamm war hier 3 m
hoch riesige
Felsen sie waren hier oder ja waren wir
wie sind sie rausgekommen mit dem
Hubschrauber gerettet ich sagte zu
meiner Frau haben wir einen Laken und
sie meinte ja was willst du damit machen
ich sagte ich werde Hilfe darauf
schreiben sie meinte schreib besser SOS
und ich dachte das ist eine gute Idee
ich ging raus und malte SOS mit dem
Schlamm und dann kamen sie sie lieen
einen Mann runter und sie sagten wir
waren nicht sicher ob es SOS oder eine
Vorwahl war es sah aus wie
805 ich muss an meiner Handschrift
arbeiten aber wir hatten Glück wir
konnten es uns leisten es sind ja
Menschen gestorben oder oh ja
schrecklich die Leute wurden über unser
Grundstück gespült und wir hatten Glück
wir hatten das Geld um das Haus zu
renovieren aber stellen Sie sich die
Menschen vor die überall auf der Welt
mit dem Klimawandel zu kämpfen
haben so fängt es an man liest darüber
und es scheint weit weg zu sein aber
dann passiert etwas und zack ist es
direkt bei
dir oh mein
Gott
Worte können es nicht
beschreiben Worte können es nicht
beschreiben die globalen Finanzsysteme
sind eng miteinander verbunden und
basieren auf der Immobilienfinanzierung
in Ländern wie den USA wenn man also in
eine Situation gerät in der ein
Hausbesitzer eine Versicherungsprämie
nicht zahlen kann seine Hypothek nicht
mehr bedienen kann in Verzug derät und
eine Zwangsvollstreckung einleitet setzt
man die ersten Teile der Geschichte in
Gang die wir aus den Jahren 2007 und
acht sehr gut
kennen wir sind nicht besonders gut
darin uns auf schwierige Zeiten in der
fernen Zukunft vorzubereiten obwohl wir
jetzt schon schwierige Entscheidungen
treffen müssen wenn man die Menschen in
den USA und in Großbritannien nach ihren
Stressquellen befragt dann sind es
Arbeit und
Geld kann ich unsere wirtschaftlichen
Probleme
lösen tut mir leid das weiß ich
nicht wir steuern in Bezug auf den
Klimawandel auf eine Klippe zu die
Dringlichkeit dieses Themas ist nicht zu
leugnen ich bin im Herzen des
militärischindustriellen Komplexes
aufgewachsen mein Vater wurde general
nachdem ich auf dem College war ich
besuchte die foreign Service school in
Georgetown madelbght war einer meiner
Beraterinnen am College und ich dachte
ich weiß wie die Welt funktioniert es
gibt Leute die das Sagen haben es gibt
jemanden der einen Plan hat als mein
Vater NATO Chef war und ich ihn dort
besuchen konnte und die Fragen der
Senatoren und Kongressabgeordneten hörte
wurde mir klar wow niemand hat hier das
Sagen der Fehler den die meisten von uns
machen ist zu denken dass es Menschen
gibt die die Dinge leiten dass jemand
einen Masterplan
hat dass es eine Kabale oder
Verschwörung gibt die hinter allem steht
und alles steUt
das stimmt einfach
nicht tun wir alles was wir können um
unseren CO2 Fußabdruck zu
vergrößern wie war die Konferenz gut
gut ich glaube sie wollten wirklich
hören was vor sich geht und was die
Herausforderungen sind ja und das habe
ich ihnen gegeben wenn man über
Venezuela liest sieht man was passiert
wenn eine Wirtschaft zusammenbrecht
totaler Kollaps ich meine waren es
anfangs nur die
Ölpreise sie haben versucht eine
populistische Demokratie daraus zu
machen wo Maduro jetzt ein Diktator ist
aber angeblich mögen die Leute in
Wirklichkeit ist Kuba da drin ich war
vor etwa se Monaten in Kolumbien und man
erzählte mir dass die Kubaner zur
venezolanischen Armee gehen und sie
entwaffnen weil sie den Venezolaner
nicht trauen das ist die Art und Weise
wie man ein Land übernimmt man entledigt
sich der Sicherheitskräfte baut
zusätzliche militärische Kräfte auf und
geht dann zu den Militärs die dem Land
gegenüber loyal sein könnten und sagt
gebt uns eure Waffen ein großer Teil des
venezolanischen Militärs ist also zu
Flüchtlingen geworden oh wow sie wurden
entwaffnet und aus dem Land geschickt
und est men ein dort sind sie leben dort
sie sind dort geboren und sie kämpfen um
überleben wir bewegen uns schon in diese
Richtung bevor wir überhaupt den
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenbruch mit
bewaffneten Gruppen auf den Straßen
hatten gestern waren 20000 bewaffnete
Menschen auf der Straße das war nur eine
Demonstration sie hatten Waffen dabei
man bringt keine Waffen zu einer
Demonstration mit es se man will le
umbringen die nicht einer Meinung
sindua Zivilgesellschaft zusammenbricht
weil man keine stabile rechtsstaatliche
Regierung hat und nicht richtig in die
Infrastruktur investiert in dieser
Hinsicht ist Venezuela ein Indikator für
die Herausforderungen denen sich die
ganze Welt stellen wird viele Leute wie
aon bgos haben das Gefühl dass sie keine
andere Wahl haben es gibt keinen Strom
kein Essen kein Wasser keine
Arbeit was einst eines der reichsten
Länder Lateinamerikas war ist heute das
chaotischste und
gefährlichste so ist das nun mal in
diesen Ländern aber mit diesen Ländern
meinst du Länder die eine inkompetente
Führung
haben Länder die es nicht schaffen sich
um ihre Bevölkerung zu kümmern sondern
das durch repressive Mechanismen
kompensieren um sicherzustellen dass sie
an der Macht
bleiben ich mache mir nur Sorgen dass
das auch in den USA
passiert in einem Land wie venezuela ist
als erstes die Energieinfrastruktur
zusammengebrochen und jetzt stellen wir
dass es nicht nur um die Strom und
Ölförderung geht sondern auch die
Wasserinfrastruktur kollabiert und das
ist ein Land das tropisch ist das voller
Wasser
ist der Energiesektor hat nicht die
nötige Ausbildung oder Investition
erhalten und die Experten wurden
rausgeschmissen sodass der Sektor vor
allem der Ölsektor zusammenbricht und
das war eine wichtige Einnahmequelle für
das Land die Staudämme können nicht mehr
so viel Strom produzieren wie früher
sass auch der Elektrizitätssektor
zusammenbrecht was wiederum bedeutet
dass auch die Wasserinfrastruktur
zusammenbricht denn selbst wenn man
Leitungen hat kann man nicht alles
betreiben das führt zu
Lebensmittelknappheit Unruhen und
Geldmangel die USA und Europa sind reich
aber wenn wir zu wenig in unsere
Infrastruktur investieren und uns auf
die Zukunft vorbereiten könnten auch wir
unter diesen Folgen
leiden die Auswirkungen des Klimawandels
sind nicht linear es handelt sich
eindeutig um eine
die sich in ihrem Ausmaß dramatisch
beschleunigt wenn wir also jetzt nicht
reagieren wird sich das viel früher als
erwartet kritisch
auswirken das ist eine Krise die nur
darauf wartet zu passieren sie breitet
sich vor unseren Augen
aus wenn also in einem Film sieht
einteroid monen treffen wird aber herr
Präsident wir arbeiten seit 6 Jahren an
diesem potenziellen Problem im
wirklichen Leben wird der Asteroid jeden
auslöschen das gleiche gilt für den
Klimawandel das gleiche gilt für eine
ganze Reihe von Problemen die wir haben
denn wenn die Leute etwas im Fernsehen
sehen und Politik ist ein
vertrauensspiel die Leute sehen den
Politiker an und denken er muss ja
wissen wovon er spricht oder sie muss ja
wissen wovon sie spricht das heißt aber
nicht dass es einen tatsächlichen Plan
mit einer systemischen Maschinerie
um Ergebnisse zu
erzielen wenn das Wasser zurückgeht
werden sich die finanziellen Kosten
summieren sind Sie es Leid in einem
solchen Haus zu leben wenn sie
eigentlich in einem solchen Haus leben
wollen schauen wir mal
rein wir haben tonnenweise Immobilien am
Wasser und jeden Tag kommen neue hinzu
century 22 jetzt auch für Gebiete in
[Musik]
Kalifornien
diejenigen von euch die auf den Berg
geklettert sind und sich auf 5 m
frischen Pulverschnee gefreut haben gut
gemacht aber wie ihr seht kommt eine
hitzefront auf uns zu sodass wir morgen
um die 68° bekommen also solltet ihr
vielleicht die Badehosen
rausholen hast du den Leitartikel über
Peter Thel gelesen den Mann der mit
Technologie ein großes Vermögen gemacht
hat und der Bunker in Neuseeland gekauft
und gebaut hat den Plan ist dass wir
alle sterben werden und dann werden sie
es irgendwie überstehen auch wenn sie es
nicht tun werden aber Sie glauben dass
ihr Geld sie vor den Folgen des
Klimawandels schützen
wird es hat schon immer Leute gegeben
die den Weltuntergang vorausgesagt
haben ja ich meine ich habe gehört dass
der Klimawandel mit einem Weltkrieg
verglichen wurde der Unterschied ist
dass wir viel mehr darüber wissen was
auf uns
zukommt Sie in unsere luxuriöse
überlebenswohnung und lassen Sie sich
vom amageddon nicht
unterkriegen wenn ihr also nicht in der
Lage seid in eurem unterirdischen Bunker
Wasser Luft und Nahrung für Tausende von
Jahren zu produzieren werdet ihr es
nicht schaffen und das wahrscheinlichste
Ergebnis wird sein dass die Bauarbeiter
wahrscheinlich nicht gewerkschaftlich
organisiert die ihr bezahlt habt um
diesen Bunker für euch zu bauen genau
wissen wo er ist und Sie haben Zugang zu
allen Werkzeugen um euch auszugraben wie
ein Trüffel je eher die Menschen
anfangen ihr Geld als Werkzeug und nicht
als Ziel im Leben zu benutzen desto
schneller werden wir uns aus diesem Loch
herausgraben
können also Dad ich weiß du willst nicht
aufpassen und mit Miniaturen gefilmt
werden weil du weiß schon du willst
nicht wie der Typ in dr strange love
oder irgendein anderer general im
Ruhestand Aussehen der mit Dingen spielt
genauso sieht es aus wir müssen etwas
auf die Beine stellen sass die Leute
verstehen wie es funktioniert wir haben
hier einen Lebensmittelladen einen
anderen Laden eine Bank einen
Hausbesitzer und dann die Notdienste und
hier drüben ist die Natur oder sagen wir
mal ein anderes Land oder Afrika oder
sowas also das erste was ich tun muss
ist zu ändern wie alles aufgebaut
ist denn wir brauchen die Bank zwischen
dem country CL und allen
anderen wir haben ein res System im
Vergleich zu dem was ich als
Realwirtschaft bezeichne das ist der Ort
an dem die Menschen arbeiten produzieren
und
[Musik]
leben
wir haben versucht kapitalstrukturen
Versicherungen Finanzierungen und
Hypotheken anhand von Kinderspielzeug zu
erklären wir haben also Geld wird das
Funktionieren ich weiß nicht ob es
[Musik]
funktioniert erstens der
Lebensmittelladen ist ein Geschäft und
verdient Geld und sie bringen das Geld
auf die
Bank Lebensmittelladen und er wird vom
Lebensmittelladen bezahlt und er
beschließt ein Haus zu
kaufen er hat nicht genug Geld von
seinem Verdienst um das Haus zu kaufen
also geht er zur Bank und die Bank sagt
oh wir geben Ihnen das Geld um das Haus
zu kaufen und im Gegenzug geben Sie uns
einen
Schuldschein wir müssen uns das ha steht
es die Inspektion ja tut es und können
Sie es sich bei ihrem monatlichen
Einkommen leisten
nun sag ja
ja okay also hier ist eine Hypothek hier
ist das Geld und das ist übrigens wie
bei einer echten Bank da sind sie sich
auch nicht sicher kann der Typ das
Bezahlen sag einfach ja na los komm gib
mir das Geld wir gehen davon aus dass
die Bank Zahlungen von uns verlangt und
sie dann weitergibt in der Bilanz steht
hier ein Eingang und dort ein Eingang
und weitere Forderungen die noch
zurückkommen und wenn es wirklich wie
erwartet zurückkommt machen Sie daraus
eine Rendite und das bedeutet im Grunde
Geld aus dem Nichts zu machen früher hat
man eine Hypothek aufgenommen und gesagt
das ist ein Vermögenswert für mich denn
du zahlst jeden Monat an mich um diese
Hypothek zu Tien stimmt's es gibt kaum
eine bessere Art Geld zu
verdienen die Bank nimmt also den
Schuldschein und verkauft ihn auf dem
sogenannten
Sekundärmarkt und dafür bekommt sie eine
Gebühr
und sobald ich diese Hypothek habe und
vielleicht die Hypotheken von vielen
anderen Häusern in der Gegend und am
besten auch noch in anderen Gegenden
bringe ich das in eine Zweckgesellschaft
ein was rechtlich gesehen eine Treuhand
oder eine Kapitalgesellschaft ist
sogenannte
vermögensschutzeinrichtungen und dann
erheben sie Ansprüche gegen diesen
rechtlichen Schutz an
Investoren die packen diese
Schuldscheine also zusammen es gibt
viele von ihnen
und sie verkaufen sie z.B an
Versicherungsgesellschaften oder
ausländische Banken sie können fremd
finanziert werden das heißt ich kann mit
diesen Dingen die darlehnen sind
darlehnen
aufnehmen sie werden fremdfanziert s
dass du mehr Kredite vergeben kannst das
System generiert also immer
Geld sie können Ihr Risiko verringern
weil sie nicht nur eine hypothekau s ein
ganzes Paket von Hypotheken manchmal
kaufen Sie nur einen Teil des Zinssatzes
für ein hypothekenpaket all das wird als
Derivat
bezeichnet und es funktioniert solange
die Erwartung besteht dass der Kredit
zurückgezahlt wird dass John der Bank
jeden Monat zum richtigen Zeitpunkt Geld
gibt um seinen Anteil an dem
Schuldschein
zurückzahlen früher hat das so
funktioniert dass der einem in die Augen
sah und fragte sind sie kreditwürdig
kann ich ihnen
vertrauen die Banken behalten die
Hypotheken nicht mehr in ihren Büchern
sie verkaufen diese Hypotheken damit sie
in andere Finanzinstrumente umgewandelt
werden können so können Sie das Risiko
auf eine andere Partei
abwälzen je nachdem wie sie von den
Ratingagenturen bewertet werden sind das
seriöse Anlagemöglichkeiten für pensond
sicher ja Pensionsfonds Pack da rein die
Investoren kaufen also einen Anteil am
Cashflow der von den Hauseigentümern in
den von uns geschaffenen Pool fließt
haben aber auch eine Art Anspruch auf
dieses Haus weil dieser Cashflow durch
die Hypothek auf das Haus gesichert ist
etwas so illiquides wie dieses Gebäude
und das Grundstück auf dem es steht kann
also durch eine geeignete rechtliche
Codierung zu einem global handelbaren
finanziellen Vermögenswert werden das
ist ihr Kredit er wandert durch dieses
System die Bank hat den Kredit verkauft
ihn er wird zum Wertpapier er wird Teil
der Bilanz von
Geldmarktfonds diese Geldmarktfonds
tauschen dann im Grunde ihren Kredit
ihre Sicherheiten ihr Haus in ein
besichertes
bargeldgeschäft und der ganze Zweck
sowohl des Bargelds als auch dieses
Geschäfts besteht darin dass es den
verschiedenen Akteuren ermöglicht auf
den derivatemärkten zu operieren und
kurzfristig sehr en zu
[Musik]
erzielen heute werden Schulden wie ein
Vermögenswert behandelt der weltweit
gehandelt werden kann wir haben also
einen gewaltigen Sprung gemacht von
sagen wir dem 12 Jahrhundert als die
ersten übertragbaren Schuldscheine
aufkamen hin zur Behandlung von Schulden
als Vermögenswert den wir auf einem
globalen Markt handeln können meine Frau
spielt Cello und ich spiele eine Reihe
von
schuldinstrumenten im gr gibt es einen
greifbaren Wert derselbe Wert wird nicht
nur einmal sondern zwei drei oder
viermal im zinsfinanzhandel
verwendet er wird nicht für produktive
Investitionen in Unternehmen verwendet
er wird auch nicht für die Finanzierung
von Klimaschutz und dekarbonisierung
verwendet Geld schafft mehr Geld
Reichtum schafft mehr Reichtum das ist
ein Kreislauf der sich immer weiter
dreht endlich sind es unsere Häuser die
den Wert unserer Häuser ausmachen die
das alles Stützen der Internationale
Währungsfond hat es das
Schattenbankensystem genannt Schatten
heißt nicht dass es illegal ist es heißt
auch nicht dass es zwangsläufig
zwielichtig ist man sagt nur Schatten
weil es keine Regeln gibt so gut wie
keine es ist fast so etwas wie der Wilde
Westen des
Finanzsektors Problem mit dem
Derivatemarkt ist es gibt keinen Markt
es ist wie ein Tauschgeschäft zwischen
bänern unter vier Augen hey ich kenne da
eine Bank ich habe einige Anleihen und
möchte dass Sie sie für mich versichern
falls sich der Zinssatz ändert würden
sie diese Anleihe für mich versichern
wie viel wollen Sie
dafür das ist ein gutes Geschäft ich
bekomme einen Bonus für den Abschluss
der Versicherung sie bekommen ein Bonus
dafür dass sie das Geld für die
Versicherung
einnehmen aber ich arbeite bei einer
anderen Bank du hast sie gerade gekauft
aber ich dachte mir dass ich sie auch
bekommen könnte weil ich einen Typen in
Saudi-Arabien oder China kenne der 2
Cent mehr zahlen würde und ich könnte
damit 50 riesen
machen das ist wie das alte
Versicherungsprinzip wie viele Leute
können Ihr Haus versichern kann jeder in
der Gegend eine Police über 100.000 do$
auf das Haus abschließen und jeder
100.000$ kassieren wenn das 100.000 doar
Haus
abbrennt
wir Amerikaner sind kurzsichtig wir
denken nicht langfristig Finanzsachen
waren vor 100 Jahren nicht so
kompliziert man hatte ein bisschen Geld
hat seine Rechnungen bezahlt und
Rechnungen verteilt man hat es unter der
Matratze aufbewahrt
genau die kritischen Derivate für unsere
heutigen Finanzmärkte sind eigentlich
die die das Finanzsystem 2008 zum
Einsturz gebracht haben nämlich der
kreditausfalltausch und
die falltausch ist im Grunde eine Art
Versicherungsvertrag der besagt dass der
Versicherer mir eine Gebühr zahlen muss
wenn einige Vermögenswerte auf den
Märkten an Wert
verlieren das Schöne daran war dass man
den Vermögenswert nicht selbst halten
musste das ist so als würde ich eine
Feuerversicherung für das Haus meines
Nachbarn abschließen wenn das Haus
abbrennt bekomme ich die Prämie der Wert
dieser
Finanztransaktion viel größer als das
Realkapital das im Grunde die Häuser der
Familien der Haushalte sind der fiktive
Wert des derivatemarkts beträgt 600
Billionen Dollar das ist etwa bis Z Mal
so viel wie das weltweite
[Musik]
Bruttoinlandsprodukt eine
amerikanischead Wert von mehreren
Billionen Dollar mindestens aber
hunderten von Milliarden wird es also
nicht mehr geben wie kann das
funktionieren wie funktioniert das im
Bankensektor auf dem Versicherungsmarkt
was wurde mit diesen Immobilien
besichert es handelt sich nicht nur um
verschiedene Akteure die sich auf
verschiedenen Märkten oder in
verschiedenen Rechtsgeschäften
austauschen unser Finanzsystem ist so
beschaffen dass wir riesige Banken haben
megabanken die zu groß sind um zu
scheitern die sehr oft beide Seiten
desselben Marktes
bedienen die großen Banken wissen nicht
unbedingt wie viel Risiko ihre
Gegenpartei in einem anderen Land bereit
ist
einzugehen niemand versteht wirklich die
rechtlichen verpflechtungen in diesen
Verträgen die letztendlich das gesamte
Finanzsystem zum Einsturz bringen können
das System ist so kompliziert dass die
Rechenschaftspflicht verloren
geht eigentliche Wert liegt also hier
das sind all die Transaktionen die auf
der realen Wirtschaft aufgebaut
[Musik]
sind das ist gar nicht so
schlecht
[Musik]
da ist doati die kleine Stadt doati da
gibt es heute nicht mehr
viel es war einmal eine Stadt die einen
Gemischtwarenladen hatte als ich
auffugs eine
[Musik]
Kirche ein Postamt aber das gibt es
nicht
mehr die Bauern im ländlichen Amerika
haben einen Vorgeschmack auf die
Automatisierung bekommen die in den
nächsten 10 Jahren auf den Rest des
Landes zukommen
wird wir sind hier auf dem Stadtplatz in
dewit arkans und wenn man sich umschaut
gibt es hier nicht so viele Unternehmen
aber eines der meistbchäftigten ist das
Department Human
Services wenn wir die Realwirtschaft
definieren sollten wir die
landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe nicht
vergessen 88% sind immer noch kleine
Familienbetriebe das ist ein
Getreidespeicher aus dem Familienbetrieb
meiner
Eltern das ist der Hof meines Vaters er
wird bald 87 meine Mutter ist 85 sie
leben hier seit
also viele
Jahre wie oft muss man starke Regenfälle
Hitzeperioden und Frost zum falschen
Zeitpunkt erleben damit die Ernte
ausfällt wir schützen unsere Landwirte
wir geben Ihnen eine ernteversicherung
und die wird subventioniert wir haben
Beratungsdienste für die sie zahlen aber
Sie zahlen wahrscheinlich nicht die
vollen Kosten dafür es ist eine freie
Marktwirtschaft aber es ist auch eine
Frage der nationalen
[Musik]
Sicherheit das Bundesprogramm zur
ernteversicherung wurde nach den
Staubstürmen und der Großen Depression
ins Leben gerufen
viele Gebiete in den USA waren von den
Staubstürmen schwer betroffen viele
Bauern haben alles verloren die
Depression verwüstete nicht nur weite
Teile Amerikas sondern auch die
Landwirte l in dieser Zeit besonders
[Musik]
stark viele Teile der Ebenen waren
völlig mit Staub bedeckt
viele ernten gingen aufgrund des Wetters
der extremen Witterung und durch
Insekten
verloren es sind wie mein Vater sagte
die großen Ereignisse vor denen sich
jeder fürchtet wie z.B eine große
Dürre
ich glaube dass unser
Grundwasserspeicher an einigen Stellen
nur noch 20% und an vielen anderen
Stellen 50% beträgt wir verbrauchen mehr
Wasser als jemals
zuvor wir haben unsere Pumpanlagen in
Betrieb genommen und bauen an Kanälen
das ist eigentlich die erste Phase wir
versuchen dies bi mit Wasser zu
versorgen dass wir dann für die
Hauptversorgung nutzen
werden in Ark werden wir in jeder
Wachstumsperiode eine Dürre
erleben dabei spielt keine Rolle z.bpi
bei der letzten Überschwemmung die wir
hier hatten sobald wir aus dem
Hochwasserereignis herauskamen mussten
wir bewässern weil unser Boden nicht
mehr tief ist wir haben eine harte
Schicht ziemlich nah unter der
Oberfläche das hilft beim reiseeinbau ja
sehr
hilfreich es wird bloß jeden Tag teurer
wir dachten dass wir vielleicht eine
Menge Geld für die Infrastruktur
bekommen würden aber das ist nicht
passiert infrastrukturgelder des
Bundes nun ursprünglich hieß es dass die
Regierung für 65% aufkommen würde und
der Bezirk für
25 und davon profitieren viele Leute
nicht nur die
Landwirte aber Sie müssen dafür bezahlen
weil sie das Wasser tatsächlich
nutzen und ich gehe davon aus dass wir
eine ganze Menge solcher Dinge tun
müssen wenn die Temperaturen steigen und
sich die getreidemuster ändern jeder mit
dem wir über die Landwirtschaft und die
verschiedenen Anbaumethoden gesprochen
haben ob mit oder ohne direktsat ob
biologisch oder nicht jedes Stück Land
ist anders
und jede Gemeinde ist anders und das
Ökosystem
dort wie kann also ein Riese wie JP
Morgan einer Gemeinde wie dieser
helfen ja und warum sollten sie das
wollen das ist der Rest der Geschichte
ich meine hier winkt kein großer Profit
wenn sie hierherkmen und sich einen Mann
Anschauen der Taus hekar bewirtschaftet
die suchen nach Farmen mit 5 bis 1000
HEK bei denen sie es rechtfertigen
können etwas Zeit darauf zu verwenden
die Banken sind so groß geworden früher
waren es diese kleineren Banken die dein
Vater und dessen Vater kannten wenn man
zu einem farmverkauf ging und sagte hey
ich mag diesen Traktor und er kostete
27000 000 dann rief man einfach die Bank
an und sagte hey ich brauche Geld okay
es ist auf ihrem
Konto vor 60 Jahren hat man Geld
verdient wenn man etwas geerntet hat wen
man erteinfuhr konnte man alle
Rechnungen bezahlen seine Kinder zur
Schule schicken und Lebensmittel
einkaufen es ging einem gut heute kann
man eine Ernte einfahren und sein
Vermögen
verlieren alle hier draußen wir sind
eine
Familie Jahren wir das Gemach haben ein
mcher 3000
gekostet und jetzt kostet ein mädrcher
000 wenn man sich Maschinen anguckt dann
ist es so dass man mit dem ganzen
Zubehör fast eine halbe Million Dollar
los
wird wonst kauft jemand eine Ausrüstung
für eine halbe Million Dollar obwohl man
so schonum über die Runden
kommt es wird von Jahr zu Jahr
schwieriger die Produktionskosten und
die Kosten für die Landwirtschaft
einfach nur Landwirt zu sein sogar ein
kleinerer Landwirt das ist fast
unerschwinglich es sei denn Ihre Familie
ist seit Generationen in der
Landwirtschaft
tätig ich danke Gott dem Allmächtigen
für eine so gut aussehende Ernte während
andere zu kämpfen hatten
oh hier sind ein paar Leute ja die holen
ein die holen jetzt alle
ein ich treffe euch oben am Tank okay
danke Z wir sehen uns
dort Bauernhöfe sind wie ein
Eigentumshaus man muss die dachin
säubern man muss den burgersteig fegen
das muss man auch auf einem Bauernhof es
gibt bestimmte Wartungsarbeiten die
jedes Jahr durchgeführt werden müssen
auf
erhten bevor die Automatisierung kam
wurde hier alles mit der Hand
reingeschrieben
1955 jeder Tag das ist alles was an dem
Tag passiert ist das ganze Geld das
reinkam sie haben vier Kredite vergeben
das sind die Kredite die wir an diesem
Tag vergeben haben hier ist die Höhe der
Kredite 150
500 auf dem Lande in ganz Amerika nicht
nur in unserer ländlichen gemeindeondern
auch in anderen gab es früher viele
kleine gemeinschaftsbanken die sehr eng
mit den Menschen die dort lebten
verbunden waren und versuchten ihn zu
helfen ihre Geschäfte auszubauen ich
habe einfach Angst davor wie die
Landschaft in Zukunft aussehen wird sie
sind nur eine Nummer auf einer Anleihe
und hier können Sie jetzt Ihren Scheck
hinschicken es wird für diese Landwirte
immer schwieriger im Geschäft zu bleiben
weil sie keine Finanzierung
bekommen denn mit jedem Jahrem sie
Verluste machen haben sie keine Hoffnung
mehr dass die Preise im nächsten Jahr
besser werden unabhängig von
Naturkatastrophen und anderen
Ereignissen so gerät der Landwirt immer
weiter ins Hintertreffen und wir hatten
schon mehrere Bauern die tatsächlich
ihren Betrieb aufgeben mussten sie
müssen Ihre Ausrüstung verkaufen und den
Hof an jemand anderen
übergeben das ist etwas worauf ich
keinen Einfluss habe und keiner von uns
hier in irgendeinen Einfluss
darauf bei der letzten Krise im Jahr
2008 als es hieß dass die Banken den
Landwirten kein Geld mehr leihen würden
habe ich einige Landwirte getroffen die
sich die Haare gerauft
haben einer fragte mich ob ich ihm genug
Geld leihen könnte um die Ernte
fertigzustellen ich habe ihm gesagt er
soll einfach nach Hause gehen und Andy
Griffith gucken hör auf CNN und Fox zu
gucken ich habe gesagt wir werden das
Geld schon zusammen beekommen wir werden
uns um dich
kümmern guck einfach nicht mehr diese
diese Sachen die dir Angst machen ja
über die man keine Kontrolle hat und
dann ein paar Wochen später kam er
zurück und sagte wissen Sie was das war
der beste Rad den ich in diesem Jahr
bisher bekommen habe die
Niederschlagsmengen wir bekommen nicht
mehr einen Zentimeter es sind entweder 3
cm oder gar nichts alles ist
extrem
viele dieser Beschränkungen für Banken
werden
aufgeweicht es gibt immer noch den
Handel mit Derivaten wir wissen was es
ist es gibt hunderte von Billionen
Dollar vielleicht 600 vielleicht 800
Billionen Dollar an Derivaten an den
Devisenbörsen die nicht abgedeckt werden
können
es ist wie nach den 80er Jahren oh
Gordon Geko ist ein toller Typ er hat
uns gelehrt dass gear gut ist sieh dir
an was es uns gebracht hat es ist ein
Kreislauf in Amerika man muss Wohlstand
schaffen man kann keinen Wohlstand
schaffen indem man ihn anderen Menschen
durch Steuern wegnimmt die Menschen
müssen einen Anreiz haben Wohlstand zu
schaffen okay aber warte mal das sind
die großen Tugenden der westlichen
Demokratie seit 300 Jahren aber es wird
auch massiv
missverstanden gehen wir mal zurück zum
ürer zum Wachstum das Wachstum wurde mit
Land erzielt auf dem die Menschen
getötet von dem sie vertrieben
wurden und sie sagten hey Mann sie dir
all das freie Land an so wurde Geld
gemacht man muss sich klar machen dass
wir es in Zukunft besser machen
können der amerikanische Kapitalismus
kann ziemlich herzlos sein wenn man sich
den amerikanischen Bürer ansieht und was
direkt danach geschah wir haben Amerika
industrialisiert wir lebten das goldene
Zeitalter die Menschen sahen sich diese
Raubritter an und sagten das kann so
nicht
weitergehen und wir landeten bei der
progressiven Bewegung das ist das
Zeitalter von regagan die regaganer war
die Lockerung des
verwaltungsstaates es war die Art von
lass die großen Firmen größer werden
lasst uns Geld machen lassen wir die
Wohlfahrtsverbände sich um die Menschen
kümmern vergessen wir die staatlichen
Programme so lief das seit der Wahl von
Reagan ich bin als rote aufgewachsen ich
bin in einer roten Familie aufgewachsen
in den 80er
Jahren
ich war in Ronald Dragon verliebt ich
habe regagan vergöttert ich sah regagan
und sagte ich will seinen Job meine
Eltern erzählten mir sogar dass ich ihm
eine Dollarnote schickte ich habe den
Geldschein mit meinem Bild darauf
verunstaltet die Maxime
lautet vertrauen ist gut Kontrolle ist
besser
ich wollte in die Politik gehen ich
wollte die erste weibliche Präsidentin
der Vereinigten Staaten werden ich fand
das
faszinierend wir können unseren Kindern
eine unbezahlbare massive Verschuldung
und eine zerrüttete Wirtschaft
hinterlassen oder wir können Ihnen die
Freiheit in einem Land hinterlassen in
dem jeder einzelne die Möglichkeit hat
das zu sein was Gott für uns vorgesehen
hat die Leute sagen ger Wirschaft se
einess
der kam schaute sich das an und sah die
politische Notwendigkeit einer
Makroökonomie Friedman kam und sah
defizitausgaben staatliche Kontrolle und
hohe Steuern und er sagte es müsse einen
besseren Weg geben er erfand die
klassische Ökonomie neu sie nannten es
neoliberale
Ökonomie ich zitierte mil Friedman und
sagte dass die Wirtschaft der
Vereinigten Staaten nach der Anzahl der
Importe nicht der Exporte beurteilt
werden
sollte und ich dachte das sei vielleicht
ein Tippfehler oder so also habe ich ihn
gefragt ich meine ist das ihr
Ernst die trickleown Ökonomie beginnt
1980 sagen wir in den späten 70ern aber
die quintessen ist dass sie aus zwei
Teilen besteht schmeißt die Bullen raus
nicht die Bullen auf der mainstet
sondern die Bullen an der Wall Street
los sie frei lst die Banken tun was sie
wollen und hier sind wir nun 40 Jahre
nach dem Zeitalter von regagan und die
Leute schauen sich an was es gebracht
hat es hat eine Menge Leute wirklich
reich gemacht wir haben in dieser Zeit
den Kalten Krieg gewonnen nicht
unbedingt deswegen aber wir haben ihn
gewonnen und Amerika wurde zu dieser Art
von Supermacht aber für die Menschen in
Amerika ist es nicht so gut gelaufen die
Reallöhne sind gesunken die Reallöhne
sind gesunken und die Menschen in diesem
Land blicken zurück und wollen Amerika
wieder so großartig machen wie in den J
damals lag der Grenzsteuersatz bei
91% Ronald Dragon war meine Mutter
liebte ihn sie sah ihn jeden
Sonntagabend im GE Theater am Ende sagte
er immer bei General Electric ist der
Fortschritt unser wichtigstes
Produkt was würde Ronald Reagan sagen
wenn wir ihm sagen würden dass ge mehr
Geld für Aktienrückkäufe als für
Forschung und Entwicklung ausgibt 1950
waren aktienrückäufe illegal gten als
Marktmanipulation heute sehen sich
investmentanalysten dieses Unternehmen
an und sagen es ist wirklich clever ich
glaube ihre Aktien werden weiter steigen
weil sie ein wirklich tolles
Aktienrückkaufprogramm haben für die
Wirtschaft ist das nicht
gut der durchschnittliche Amerikaner
lebt im BIP von
1980 ja die Welt hat sich zwar verändert
und die Waren die man kauft sind nicht
mehr dieselben aber in Bezug auf ihren
durchschnittlichen Lebensstandard soweit
wir diesen Messen können hat es sich
nicht
verbessert die Unternehmen finanzieren
ihre Investitionen aus ihren Gewinnen
das denken die Leute aber wenn man sich
die 500 größten US-Unternehmen anguckt
werden 50% der Gewinner als Dividenden
ausgeschüttet und 50% für den Rückkauf
von Aktien verwendet wie finanzieren Sie
also sie ihre Investitionen wenn sie
sich verschuldet
haben der Präsident zeigte sich gestern
überrascht über den Einbruch der Märkte
seine immer noch anhaltende Popularität
verdankte er dem Wirtschaftsboom den
Amerika unter seiner Führung erlebt
hat es arbeiten mehr Menschen als jemals
zuvor in der Geschichte unsere
Produktivität ist gestiegen es gibt
keine galoppierende Inflation wie in der
Vergangenheit wie gesagt ich glaube
nicht dass jemand in Panik geraten
sollte denn alle Wirtschaft indoren sind
solide aber die Warnzeichen sind schon
lange da in den geschlossenen Fabriken
in vielen
Kleinstädten es gibt diese Vorstellung
von Milliardären die Arbeitsplätze
schaffen das ist die trickleown
Wirtschaft das Problem ist dass das in
der Geschichte noch nie passiert ist so
etwas wie eine trickleown Ökonomie gibt
es nicht sie existiert einfach nicht es
ist voodu
Ökonomie
wenn man die klügsten Köpfe der Welt in
die Finanzwelt steckt was wir in den
letzten 25 Jahren getan haben kann man
ihre Fantasie und ihre Kreativität nicht
aufhalten die Geschwindigkeit und das
Ausmaß des globalen wirtschaftlichen
Wandels haben die nationalen
regulierungssysteme überwältigt wir
werden eine strengere und transparentere
Überwachung von Banken hgefonds und dem
sogenannten globalen
Schattenbankensystem vereinbaren
nehmen wir an ich bin ein Banker wenn
die Aufsichtsbehörden kommen sind wir
eine sehr einfache kleine Bank sie
schauen sich unsere Verfahren an die du
Diligence Prüfung von Projekten die wir
gemacht haben das ist ziemlich einfach
dann gehen Sie zu einer großen Bank
Wells oder JP Morgan oder Goldman und
sie als Aufsichtsbehörde fragen sich was
ist das all diese E-Mails sie verstehen
es nicht weil sie nicht in diesem
Bereich arbeiten das ist so als würde
man versuchen den Leuten die Gravitation
zu erklären wenn man einen Highschool
Physikkurs absolviert hat und jetzt
Stephen Hawking inspizieren
soll die Erde ist ein reichhaltiges
natürliches System das ich nicht ewig
ausdehnen kann das schöne am
Rechtssystem und Derivate sind ein Teil
davon ist dass wir es so weit ausdehnen
können wie wir wollen also schaffen wir
immer neue Arten von Vermögenswerten
letztendlich schaffen wir neue Arten von
juristischen Tricks und die beiden
Systeme sind nicht ohne weiteres
kompatibel
wenn sie reich sind und mit ihrem Geld
spielen und es in Las Vegas verlieren
ist das ihr Problem aber wenn Sie Ihr
Geld hier verlieren ist es unser
Problem der Markt kann nicht für Dinge
bestrafen von denen er keine Ahnung hat
und sie haben keines der Risiken
einkalkuliert dass sich das alles ändern
könnte eine Naturkatastrophe könnte
große Auswirkungen auf unser
Finanzsystem haben weil sie sich auf die
Vermögenswerte
Wirt das neue Gesetz erlaubt es den 12
Federal Reserve banks zusätzliches Geld
für gute Vermögenswerte auszugeben
sodass die Banken die wieder öffnen in
der Lage sein werden jede legitime
Forderung zu erfüllen es handelt sich um
eine solide Währung weil sie durch
tatsächliche gute Vermögenswerte gedeckt
ist
was also passiert ist dass es ein
Ereignis gibt und wenn das Ereignis
eintritt Wachen alle auf und plötzlich
gibt es das was wir im Finanzsystem
Ansteckung nennen die Leute entladen
sich sie stoßen Aktien ab sie versuchen
ihre Derivate zurückzubekommen sie
wollen ihre Versicherungspolicen
einlösen und der marktgerät ins Wanken
wenn der Markt zu kollabieren beginnt
werden überall die Stecker gezogen beim
Klimawandel haben wir es also nicht nur
mit den direkten Auswikungen zu tun
sondern auch mit der Möglichkeit einer
Ansteckung wirtschaftliche Ansteckung
finanziell diese Ansichten sind nur
Prognosen und werden sich mit dem
Eintreffen neuer Informationen
weiterentwickeln wir haben gesagt dass
wir diese Finanzakteure retten werden
wir werden
sieetten halten
werden es läuft nur weil die
Zentralbanken eingreifen und
Vermögenswerte kaufen dann wurde
kürzlich vorgeschlagen dass die
Europäische Zentralbank anfangen sollte
Aktien von Unternehmen zu kaufen also
nicht nur Schulden sondern auch Aktien
wir sozialisieren also die Verpflichtung
finanzerträge für die Inhaber von
Kapitalvermögen zu schaffen das kann
nicht ewig so
weitergehen
auch wenn alle Politiker sagen das ist
die wichtigste Wahl deines Lebens werden
diese Kräfte nicht durch eine einzige
Wahl gebändigt oder
entfesselt in den letzten Wochen haben
wir in den Nachrichten über das
Coronavirus gelesen und chinare die
zombalyse ich habklich einissst
voronir nicht in ein Flugzeug steigen
aber haben wir eine Regierung die
kompetent genug ist um eine solche
Reaktion zu
bewältigen nein wir können ja nicht
einmal mit der Obdachlosigkeit in LA
umgehen wir kriegen es nicht einmal hin
etwas richtig zu finanzieren geschweige
den eine
[Musik]
Pandemie die Amerikaner Leben in der
Illusion dass sie sich total von anderen
Menschen unterscheiden als ich auf dem
College war als auf dem Balkan alles
zusammen molz sagten sie diese Leute
sind wilde sie bekämpfen sich schon seit
hunderten von Jahren es ist als ob sie
gerade von den Bäumen heruntergekommen
wären oder so dann ist man dort und
stellt fest dass diese Menschen in
Häusern leben die Strom haben und
Garagen mit zwei Autos und Kühlschränke
und nicht nur Kinder die studieren
sondern mehrere Generationen die
studiert haben und sie sprechen alle
dieselbe
Sprache und diese Menschen haben sich
gegenseitig gebracht sie haben einen
Völkermord begangen 250 000 Tote
vergewaltigungslager Konzentrationslager
ethnische
Säuberung der Plan war den Kosovo
ethnisch zu säubern und die albanische
Bevölkerung
loszuwerden werden wir das dulden wird
Frankreich das dulden das glaube ich
nicht wie in vielen Ländern beginnt ein
System zusammenzubrechen in Ihrem Fall
war es das kommunistische System und in
unserem fallnt unser kapitalistisches
System zusammenzubrechen und die
Menschen gehen aufeinander los weil
einige Anführer denken jeder ist gerade
verärgert und ich kann meine Gruppe
motivieren einer anderen Gruppe etwas
wegzunehmen seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
hat Europa nicht mehr so viele
vertrieben
gesehen und das sind die Dinge über die
wir uns beim Klimawandel Sorgen machen
müssen denn das passiert wenn die
Ressourcen knapp werden und jeder ist
ein Mensch jeder ist anfällig für diese
Dinge wir haben Bretter zu geseg die wir
vor die Fenster machten für den Fall das
Plünderer kommen um das Haus zu
schützen die Vereinten Nationen sagten
erst vor zwei Wochen eine Milliarde
innerhalb von 30 Jahren eine Milliarde
vertriebene weil sie wegen der Dürre
oder Überschwemmungen oder des
Zusammenbruchs von Systemen ihre
Nahrungsmittel nicht mehr so anbauen
können wie früher wie viel schlimmer
wird es noch werden bevor es besser
wird die allgemeine Ansicht ist die
itlechter die nächsten Regenfälle werden
noch eine Weile auf sich warten
lassen für die Welt ist das eine sehr
schlimme Sache denn es geht um
Milliarden von Menschen die umgesiedelt
werden und um massive wirtschaftliche
Folgen kann eine Gesellschaft die in
materieller Hinsicht so erfolgreich war
wie diese sich selbst verändern in der
Vergangenheit waren Imperien nicht in
der Lage das zu
tun sagen könnten Sie uns
helfen unwahrscheinlich
unwahrscheinlich das Erbe Amerikas ist
römisch weißt du die Männer die die
Verfassung geschrieben haben haben die
Geschichte Roms studiert der Senat ist
er ist römisch und er versagt so wie der
römische Senat versagt hat es gab einen
griechischen Philosophen der sagte dass
Regierungen Zyklen
durchlaufen sie gehen von der Demokratie
über das Oligopol
zur Diktatur und brechen dann zusammen
du sprichst von
Aristoteles das war nicht Aristoteles
das war jemand anderes nein es war
Aristoteles nein es war vielleicht
Polybius ich habe es vergessen ich wette
mit dir um Geld dass es Aristoteles ist
weil wir in Vegas sind ich wette mit dir
um Bargeld dass es Aristoteles ist
aristoteles hat die drei Arten von
Regierungen und ihre Alter Egos
definiert ESB e die wenn sie schlecht
läuft zu einer mobokratie
wird es gibt eine Monarchie die wenn sie
schiefgeht zur Tyranei
wird und es gibt eine Aristokratie die
wenn sie schlecht läuft zu einem
Oligopol
wird er baut auf der Arbeit eines
Vorgängers auf wie lautet der Name des
Vorgängers das müssen wir
herausfinden ich weiß es nicht sag's mir
wir finden es raus ich weiß es nicht ich
muss es nachschlagen
Reichtum wurde vor allem durch den
Handel
erlangt in die Lagerhäuser strömten
waren aus dem ganzen Reich und darüber
hinaus es waren eher die wenigen Reichen
als die vielen die von den Reichtümern
und enormen Ressourcen des Reiches
profitierten dieses Ungleichgewicht und
das unverantwortliche Verhalten der
Beamten sollten zu den Hauptgründen für
den Niedergang Roms
werden war das nicht letzte Woche in den
Nachrichten
und du musst herausfinden ob ich recht
habe oder er es geht um Aristoteles oh
junge ich weiß ich weiß also ich dachte
mir na ja Aristoteles beschreibt den Tod
der Demokratie und was mit verschiedenen
Regierungsformen passiert wenn sie
zerfallen
im des Übergangs zum Mittelalter in der
Spätantike nahm die soziale Ungleichheit
stärker zu als je
zuuvor die Reichen wurden immer reicher
und die Armen immer
ärmer der Grund dafür liegt darin dass
das römische Reich und seine
Zentralregierung den ärmsten Teil der
Bevölkerung nicht unterstützten was sie
vorher noch getan
hatten
dasselbe Muster lässt sich auch in der
heutigen Gesellschaft
beobachten die Mittelschicht ist
besonders betroffen und leidet immer
mehr unter der Rezession die wir seit
Anfang der 2000er Jahre
Erle weißt du Alessia ich weiß auch aus
deinen Studien dass der Zusammenbruch
des Römischen Reiches vor allem ein
riesiger enormer gigantisch finanzieller
Zusammenbruch
war irgendwann ging den Kaisern einfach
das Geld
aus es gibt viele verschiedene Theorien
warum das römische Reich
zusammengebrochen ist was wir heute
wissen ist dass es einen langen
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang gab bevor
die deutschen Horden kamen und Italien
und schließlich Rom
eroberten die Frage ist also was hat den
langen Wirts
die Ungleichheit zwischen den Reichen
und den
armenoris und humilioris ja du sprichst
jetzt Latein ja
Latein massive Ungleichheit kann
politisch nicht nachhaltig sein
Regierungen finanzieren sich entweder
durch Schulden oder durch
Steuern in Rom würde man im Grunde
versuchen mehr Erträge aus den besetzten
Provinzen herauszuholen oder man würde
einen weiteren Krieg beginnen um die
Erträge zu die R ernähren und diejenigen
ernähren die das System insgesamt
betreiben ich glaube das ist der
gemeinsame Nenner denn wir leben heute
in einem ganz anderen System heute sind
es unsere Zentralbanken die die
Rettungsaktion
durchführen eine der wirklichen Stärken
der Finanzmärkte besteht darin dass sie
Maßnahmen aus der Zukunft in die
Gegenwart verlagern können wenn es eine
glaubwürdige Politik gibt schließlich
ist das meiste was die Zentralbanken tun
genau
das
große Bäume fallen schwer der Markt kann
sich an alles anpassen solange es
Klarheit Transparenz und Ehrlichkeit
gibt und ich glaube nicht dass wir das
bekommen es gab eine Menge Dinge die das
Problem verursacht haben aber im
Wesentlichen hat die Struktur Roms lange
Zeit zusammengehalten bis ihr
schließlich die wirtschaftlichen
Möglichkeiten und die Führung
ausgingen Politiker wurden gekauft die
Gründer unserer Republik haben uns immer
wieder davor gewarnt dass wenn man
wirklich reich wird und seinen
moralischen Charakter verliert es vorbei
ist genau da sind wir jetzt weil wir
sehr nahe an einem Moment sind in dem
wir anfangen könnten langsam
abzurutschen und wenn wir nicht sehr
vorsichtig sind werden wir schneller und
schneller und schneller und schneller
und schneller
Achterbahn das wird eine Menge Spaß
machen vielleicht sie kenten
mögen sie in interessanten Zeiten
leben so ist es also beim letzten mal
ausgegangen nur dass es diesmal nicht
nur Barbaren sind sondern es ist der
Planet selbst der in Flammen
aufgeht es gibt hier immer noch ein
aktives Feuer behalten Sie die Lage im
Auge und informieren Sie sich was Sie
tun müssen wenn Feuer näher kommt in den
rauchigen Nachwehen des schlimmsten
Staats in die feuersaison an der man
sich erinnern kann suchen die einen nach
Lösungen die anderen nach einem
Schuldigen vielleicht sollten wir eine
Pause einlegen damit sich alles
einspielen
kann finanzieller Einfallsreichtum ist
Teil dieses Systems seit die
Niederländer die Gesellschaft mit
beschränkter Haftung erfunden haben okay
aber ein Großteil davon ist nicht
finanziell aber Papa hör zu jeder dachte
Bernie madof sei ein
Genie ausländische Investoren schauten
auf die USA und sagten die Vereinigten
Staaten sind der sicherste Ort auf der
Welt an dem ich mein Geld anlegen
kann wir hatten ich weiß nicht fün se
biblische Ereignisse wir werden Sie auch
weiterhin
haben ich muss also den Wert und die
Rentabilität meines Landes auf lange
Sicht in Frage
stellen
vor etwas mehr als 7 Jahren fegte der
Hurricane Sandy hierdurch und
verursachte Sachschäden in Höhe von
mehreren Milliarden Dollar und seitdem
hat New York mehr größere höhere und
teurere Gebäude
gebaut weil wir die Menschen für die
Kosten der Versicherung aufkommen müssen
falls ein weiterer Hurric
das nationale
hochwasserversicherungsprogramm ist
stlich und öffentlich es wird von der
nationalen Katastrophenhilfe verwaltet
es bietet hochwasserversicherungen für
praktisch alle Hausbesitzer und
Kleinunternehmen im Land
istentlichlich anderen Ländern gibt es
private Märkte für
hochwasserversicherung in den USA
[Musik]
nicht es handelt sich um eine
Zusatzversicherung die von der Regierung
subventioniert wird sodass alle Bürger
bis zu einem gewissen Grad die Rechnung
für die Eigentümer von Immobilien an der
Küste
bezahlen um eine riesige Wohnanlage in
einem Überschwemmungsgebiet in New York
City zu bauen braucht man natürlich eine
Menge Kapital die kommunalen Akte New
York City sind sehr daran interessiert
weiterhin eine Version von New York City
zu fördern in der ein möglichst großer
Teil des verfügbaren Landes für die
weitere wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
nutzbar
bleibt weil die Grundsteuern dort so
wichtig sind wie auch
anderswo das nationale
hochwasserversicherungsprogramm sollte
ursprünglich den Bau von Gebäuden in
sehr gefährdeten Gebieten stoppen in
Gebieten in denen sich das Wasser mit
heres
bewegt vor allem in
Überschwemmungsgebieten entlang des
Flusses in denen sich das Wasser mit der
gleichen Geschwindigkeit wie der Fluss
bewegt und in Hurricane Zonen in denen
die Sturmflut ankommt es ist fast
unmöglich ein sicheres Gebäude zu bauen
das einer 2 m hohen Wasserwand standhält
die bei einer Sturmflut auf einen
zukommt es gibt viele Interessengruppen
denen das egal ist z.B die
Bauindustrie sie würden gerne ein Haus
am Strand bauen solange sie es verkaufen
können bevor die Flut kommt
und wenn sie es dann verkauft haben
liegt das Risiko bei jemand
anderem die Art und Weise wie die
Finanzakteure im Vorfeld der letzten
Finanzkrise Hypotheken verbrieft haben
ist immer noch
aktuell die baauunternehmer wollen alle
das hochwasserprogramm Minimieren die
Stadt will es minimieren will die
Pegelstände auf den Karten klein halten
und kämpft gegen jede Karte die vom
hochwasserversicherungsprogramm
herausgegeben wird das führt zu
Verzögerungen bei der Umsetzung
vielleicht sogar zur
Nichtumsetzung die Küstengemeinden
befinden sich in einigen der
wertvollsten Gegenden des Landes und
deshalb werden die Menschen kämpfen um
ihre Investitionen zu
schützen ich dachte okay die Stadt
verlangt nicht dass ich eine
hochwasserversicherung habe mein
Immobilienmakler hat mir nicht gesagt
dass ich eine haben muss
ehrlich gesagt schaut man sich die
hochwasserkarten nicht an wenn man
irgendwo hinzieht man verliebt sich
einfach in das Haus und 85% meiner
Nachbarn waren nicht
versichert die USA sind besonders
anfällig dafür in Katastrophen
gefährdeten physisch gefährdeten
Gebieten zu bauen weil wir uns auf
lokale Regeln
verlassen vor allem bei Entscheidungen
über die
Raumordnung
Gehör staten zu den Rechten der
Bundesstaaten und zu den Rechten der
Kommunen und das hat viele Vorteile aber
auch einen großen Nachteil die Kommunen
sind auf Einnahmen angewiesen die von
ihren Gebäuden von ihren Einwohnern
stammen die in ihren Orten bauen und
leben und das bedeutet dass alle
Einwohner von der Entwicklung
profitieren
die Politik der Bereitstellung ist in
den USA so stark mit den
Grundstückswerten verknüpft dass wenn
die Grundstückswerte sinken die
steuerveranlagungen entsprechend
angepasst werden und man weniger
Einnahmen für die Steuerbasis erzielt
was weniger Investitionen in lokale
Einrichtungen Schulen und den
öffentlichen Nahverkehr
bedeutet in Texas haben wir keine
staatliche Einkommenssteuer das ist ein
weiterer Grund warum man hier leben
möchte denn es ist billig
aber die Leute werden auf ihr Land
besteuert die bestehenden Karten die
zeigen wo ein 100 oder 500 jährliches
Hochwasser auftritt sind so veraltet und
ungenau dass das Risiko und die Kosten
dieses Risikos selbst in der
Versicherungsbranche nicht so genau sind
wie sie sein müssten damit wir die
Kosten des Klimas einschätzen
können die versicherungsakteure haben
Wege gefunden Versicherungspolice zu
verbriefen und sie auf die
risikokapitalmärkte zu
übertragen das bedeutet dass Sie bereit
sind mehr und mehr Immobilien zu
versichern was wiederum bedeutet dass
die Leute weiterhin in risikoreichen
Gebieten
bauen ich glaube nicht dass irgendjemand
ein Haus angucken will wenn er dafür
durch Salzwasser kommen muss und es dann
auch noch kaufen
will das ist mein Notgroschen für meine
Kinder und meinen Ruhestand ja aber
jetzt wo Du es in einem Gebiet gekauft
hast in dem der Meeresspiegel steigt ist
dieser Notgroschen vielleicht nicht mehr
so
sicher und um seine Notgroschen in
Bargeld umzuwandeln muss er in der Lage
sein das Haus zu
verkaufen aber jetzt wird niemand mehr
die 30jährige Hypothek versichern was
passiert mit
John john hat seine Notgroschen verloren
okay also john ist jetzt buchstäblich
John auf der
Straße das schöne Haus dass sie in
Florida kaufen wollten um sich zur Ruhe
zu setzen werden sie nicht das war ihr
Haus in Florida sie wollten nach Alabama
umziehen okay nun sie werden nicht
umziehen vielleicht nach Alabama aber
sie werden dort in einem Wohnwagen
Leben bei Überschwemmungen ist die
US-Regierung auf ganz besondere Weise
beteiligt Feuer wird privat
versichert was mit dem feuerrisiko
passiert ist dass einige Erstversicherer
ihr Geschäft aufgeben
bei Ereignissen wie den waldbrenden in
Kalifornien muss ein Versicherer sein
Geschäft aufgeben wenn seine
ausstehenden Verbindlichkeiten höher
sind als die Summe die er auszahlen
kann dann haben wir uns unterhalten und
sie haben mir erzählt dass sie ein Haus
in salito kaufen wollten was ist dann
passiert wir riefen bei der Versicherung
an zwei oder drei Tage vorher und ließen
sie wissen dass wir bald unterschreiben
würden und sie sagten hey wir können das
Haus nicht versichern und wir fragen was
und sagten ja es steht auf einer Liste
von vierteln die wir nicht mehr
versichern also werden diese ganzen
Stadtteile nicht versichert sein und sie
sagten uns auch dass sie nicht wissen ob
sie den derzeitigen Besitzer des Hauses
wieder verersichern werden da sind
Häuser im Wert von Milliarden von Dollar
im ganzen Bundesstaat die ein
versicherungsproblem haben
werden die Versicherungsgesellschaften
versichern nur für ein Jahr wenn sich
die Lage also verschlimmert werden die
Gesellschaften definitiv nicht in der
Lage sein den Hausbesitzern zu Hilfe zu
kommen diese latenten versteckten
klimarisiken die an verschiedenen Orten
in verschiedenen Wohnungsmärkten
bestehen könnten sollten sie platzen das
gesamte Finanzsystem zum Einsturz
bringen im Moment ist dieses Haus für 49
000 gelistet auf dem Höhepunkt des
Marktes lag der Preis bei
250000 es sind nicht nur die Eigentümer
vereren sondern auch die Vermittler die
ihre Forderungen gegen sie verlieren es
sind diejenigen die die verbrieften
Hypotheken und Vermögenswerte gekauft
haben wie wir in der Krise 2008 gesehen
haben wenn wir nicht bereit sind immer
wieder den gleichen Check auszustellen
müssen wir anfangen zu prüfen ob wir die
Versorgungseinrichtungen und die
Infrastruktur um diese Häuser herum
ausreichend verstärken damit sie diese
Stürme in Zukunft überstehen können
oder sollten wir die Investition von
Kapital das den Bedingungen des
Klimawandels in negativer Weise
ausgesetzt sein wird tatsächlich nicht
zulassen darüber müssen wir
nachdenken das ist das wirklich
beängstigende denn wir sind nicht ich
meine sie wissen ja dass unsere
Infrastruktur nicht dafür gerüstet ist
noch nicht das ist sehr teuer manche
Leute denken darüber nach aber bisher
hat das niemand
getan vom Standpunkt eines
Ölunternehmens aus betrachtet befinden
sich die meisten großen Anlagen in den
USA und eigentlich weltweit an der
Küste aus dieser Sicht sind die Anlagen
genauso gefährdet wie die Häuser der
Menschen im Golf von Mexico gibt es eine
Menge offshore Infrastruktur die jedoch
an Land in viele Pipelines mündet die
direkt an der Küste
liegen wenn also die Küstenlinie
erodiert werden diese Pipelines sichtbar
und anfällig und müssen tiefer vergraben
oder mit einer Infrastruktur umgeben
werden um sie zu
schützen also die Stärkung der
Infrastruktur der
Versorgungseinrichtungen Brände die
damit oder mit den Pipelines in
Verbindung gebracht werden die Menschen
machen sich Sorgen darüber wie es mit
dem Schutz
weitergeht die Natur wird die Grundlagen
unserer Wirtschaft
aushölen
so manchmal bin ich an einem Ort wie
diesem und stelle mir vor wie es wäre
ohne Geld in der Tasche vor einem
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenbruch hierher
zu
[Musik]
fliehen denn wissen Sie wir haben viel
Land aber wenn ich hier draußen
überleben müsste und kein Geld hätte um
etwas kaufen das mich mit Strom versorgt
eine Möglichkeit Wasser aus einem
ziemlich trockenen Land zu holen während
wir die unberührte Natur lieben und
gerne in ihr wandern jagen
Zelten all diese Dinge die wir dank der
Technologie tun die sie im Laden gekauft
haben das Zelt das Gewehr die
Taschenlampe das
Feuerzeug diese Dinge werden in
menschlichen Gemeinschaften hergestellt
in Fari
nicht von Menschen auf der Flucht nicht
von Menschen die kein Kapital
haben es dreht sich alles ums
Kapital also passiert folgendes das
Kapital wird dorthin fließen wo es für
den Kapitaleigner das meiste Geld
einbringen kann eine Stadt wie diese die
eine silbermenenstadt war ist ein gutes
Beispiel für die Theorie der
Nahrungssuche wenn du ein Tier bist oder
diese Dinge lassen sich auch auf die
menschliche Welt übertragen du hast die
Wahl zwischen zwei Dingen einem das
leicht zu bekommen ist und einem das
schwer zu bekommen ist wenn das leicht
zu bekommende Ding mehr wert ist dann
wirst du dich dafür entscheiden das ist
es was die boomstätte hervorbringt denn
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt war das
Silber wirklich leicht zu bekommen und
etwas wert und dann als der Silbermarkt
zusammenbrach war es nichts mehr wert
also ging man weiter um die nächste
leicht zu fördernde Sache zu finden
diese Muster des Kapitals ändern sich
nicht im Laufe der
Zeit das Kapital wird immer nach der
größten Rendite Streben und sobald sich
diese Rendite nicht
auszahlt wird man die Zelte abbrechen
und woanders
hingehen wie man Kapital definiert es
ist das Geld das man verwendet um etwas
zu
schaffen
die Leute sind sehr kurzsichtig sie
schauen nur auf das was sie vor Augen
haben und auf das Portfolio direkt vor
Ihnen wie Sie kurzfristig Geld verdienen
können wie geht's
Frank also wissen Sie wir schauen uns um
und das ist das ganze Kapital das ganze
Kapital der Welt das genau hier seinen
Sitz hat und ich nehme an dass wir alle
50 hinaus leben wollen und deshalb
müssen wir uns umstellen schlagen die
sich darum bei ihnen investieren zu
dürfen nein das tun sie nicht wir müssen
nach der richtigen Art von Investoren
für unsere Projekte suchen und wenn wir
die Investoren gefunden haben ist es
extrem schwierig den Wert zu schaffen
oder den Wert für unsere Projekte
herauszuholen den die Investoren sofort
erkennen
wenn jemand bei Derivaten 15% auf sein
Geld bekommen kann warum sollte er dann
5% bei erneuerbaren Energien wollen weil
er die Steuergutschrift für
Investitionen nutzen könnte jeder will
eine Rendite und jeder will seine
Rendite maximieren und die einzigen von
denen ich weiß dass sie ihre Rendite für
Projekte im Bereich der erneuerbaren
Energien maximieren können sind die
Wohlhabenden Einzelpersonen die die ein
passives Einkommen haben und was
verstehen wir unter wohlhabenden
Personen ich glaube viele Amerikaner
denken wenn jemand 500 000 hat ist der
wohlhabend wir reden über Leute die
Hunderte von Millionen Dollar an
Nettovermögen haben also mindestens
hunderte Millionen Dollar an
Nettovermögen das würde ich so sagen
aber es gibt nicht viele Leute
vielleicht weniger als 1% der
Bevölkerung die diese Art von
Investitionen haben die ein passives
Einkommen
generieren
wenn es keine Investitionen auf dem
Markt in Richtung der Technologie gibt
die zu Klimalösungen erneuerbaren
Energien und sauberer Energie beitragen
würde dann wirkt sich das auf den
gesamten Lebenszyklus aus auf den
gesamten
geschäftsfluss Kanes der Gründer der
Makroökonomie stellte die Frage warum
investieren die Menschen ehrlich gesagt
gibt es darauf keine Antwort er nannte
es animal spirits ich kann Ihnen sagen
die Menschen sind Risikos Schu und nach
2008 sind sie sogar noch
risikoscheuer wenn ich zu diesen
Wirtschaftskonferenzen gehe und meine
Freunde sehe frage ich den Typen der 100
Millionen Dollar hat woran arbeiten sie
jetzt er antwortet ich bin zufrieden wo
ich bin bin ich habe ein Haus in Mexiko
und wir kümmern uns um die Enkelkinder
ich meine er investiert nicht in Risiken
er schafft keine Arbeitsplätze für den
Rest von uns zumindest nicht direkt das
ist der animal Spirit der derzeit in
vielen Unternehmen herrscht das kann man
nur durch staatliche Führung
ersetzen der Ei Kanal die
transkontinentale Eisenbahn der Panama
Kanal das Weltraumprogramm das
Interstate Highway System in keinem Fall
hat sich eine Gruppe von Unternehmern
zusammengetan und gesagt hey lasst uns
das Interstate Highway System bauen nein
es war ein Traum den Eisenhauer 1955
vorantrieb der aus einer Studie während
des Zweiten Weltkriegs hervorging die
zeigte dass man diese Autobahnen für die
nationale Sicherheit
brauchte das ist keine Parteipolitik
niemand hat ein Monopol auf die Wahrheit
und auf die Fakten die dieses Land
betreffen wir müssen zusammen
arbeiten die USA sind sehr uneinheitlich
wir haben Bundesstaaten Bezirke Regionen
Zehntausende von Städten und alle haben
ein Mitspracherecht es ist schwer uns
dazu zu bringen bei bestimmten Projekten
zusammenzuarbeiten es sei denn wir sind
uns darin einig dass es notwendig ist
und dringend gemacht werden muss wenn
die australische militärstudie die
usmitärstudie und die britische
militärstudie alle korrekt sind haben
wir wenn wir nichts tun etwa 30 Jahre
Zeit bis die Zivilisation zusammenbricht
was vermutlich keine gute Rendite
hat korrekt wir sind diejenigen die
Ihnen sagen dass wir den Kipppunkt
bereits überschritten haben
könnten ich glaube das übrigens
nicht wenn Sie das glauben dann ist die
Investition in Wind und Solarenergie
fast nicht mehr
[Musik]
relevant
was ist das wertvollste auf der Welt es
sind die Ölreserven im
Boden sie sind mehr wert als das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt der Vereinigten
Staaten mehr als der Aktienmarkt mehr
als die Aktienmärkte aller westlichen
Länder es ist Öl im Boden und die
Menschen die dieses Öl haben wollen dass
es genutzt wird was immer sie über
Saudiarabien hören sie werden sich von
einer erdölasierten wegbwegen ja ja aber
sie werden sich in ihrem Tempo bewegen
und sie brauchen diese Petrodollars um
dorthin
zuelangen die gesellschaftlichen Kosten
sind im Moment viel höher als die
wirtschaftlichen Kosten für die Entnahme
von Öl aus dem Boden also muss man die
gesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen erkennen
und die Leute die es produzieren und
verkaufen und die Leute die es kaufen
dazu bringen die vollen Kosten für seine
Nutzung zu zahlen das heißt eine
Steuer
aber das haben wir noch nicht mal bei
der Sicherheit gemacht ich meine
realistisch betrachtet haben wir die
Ölindustrie 50 Jahre lang subventioniert
indem wir Regierungen umgestoßen haben
indem wir die schiffahrtswege für sie
geschützt haben die ölwege also konnten
wir es nicht einmal tun wenn es darum
ging sie für ihre eigene Förderung und
Sicherheit zahlen zu lassen das stimmt
aber einer der Gründe warum wir es nicht
tun konnten ist dass wir nicht wirklich
eine Alternative hatten was ist das für
ein Geräusch wir hatten nicht wirklich
die Alternative
technisch Ingenieure arbeiten unter
Beschuss um Ölleitungen zu löschen die
von den sich zurückziehenden irakischen
Truppen in Brand gesetzt worden
waren tierische Fette und Talk konnten
den ständig wachsenden Bedarf an Kerzen
und Schmiermittel nicht mehr decken das
Walöl das lange Zeit das wichtigste
Leuchtmittel war wurde knapp doch die
Nachfrage nach künstlichem Licht stieg
im Jahr 1850 wurde eine Lampe erfunden
die ein raffiniertes Erdölprodukt
effizient
verbrannte bei der frühen ölforderung
wurde Dampfkraft verwendet und die wurde
wahrscheinlich durch die Verbrennung von
Holz oder Kohle erzeugt man brauchte
also Holz oder Kohle um Öl zu gewennen
heute nutzen wir Elektrizität oder Gas
um Öl zu gewennen wir nutzen also eine
Energieform um eine andere zu gewinnen
wir haben keine Wirtschaft die nur von
einer Energieform lebt sondern eine die
von vielen Formen
lebt
ein Teil dieser Gleichung ist die
Anpassung des Konsums und des
kulturellen Verhaltens aber darüber wird
nicht geredet keiner will jemandem die
Schuld geben wenn man der Industrie die
Schuld geben will nun die Industrie
existiert weil die Menschen ihre Dinge
kaufen oder benutzen sie sind also die
Endverbraucher sollen wir sie mit einer
kohlenstoffsteuer bestrafen vielleicht
sollten wir alle Verantwortung
übernehmen und einen Kulturwandel
herbeiführen um dahin zurückzukehren wo
wir vor 30 40 Jahren waren vielleicht
aber das ist schwer der überwiegende
Teil unseres individuellen Ausstoßes
kommt aus den Bereichen wohnen Verkehr
und Ernährung das sind große
strukturelle Probleme die man nicht
wirklich adäquat angehen kann indem man
die Marke der Papierhandtücher wechselt
die man
kauft wir leben in einer
energieverbrauchsgesellschaft und wir
müssen uns darüber im Klaren sein dass
es nichts umsonst
gibt man muss sich darüber bewusst sein
dass alles Energie kostet egal was man
[Musik]
tut so sieht der öffentliche Raum in den
USA nicht aus aber mir ist aufgefallen
dass hier in den Niederlanden jeder
überall mit dem Fahrad fährt das tun sie
ja und dafür braucht man komischerweise
kein
Benzin
[Musik]
nein die Frage ist können wir fossile
Brennstoffe durch erneuerbare Energien
ersetzen und das ist eine sehr heikle
Frage sie löst enorme Debatten aus und
die Leute werden wütenend wenn man ihn
diese Frage stellt weil nicht klar ist
was man
meint wenn man meint dass man die Gier
der Menschen mit erneuerbaren Energien
befriedigen kann dann lautet die Antwort
nein wenn Sie meinen dass erneuerbare
Energien eine ausreichende Menge an
Energie erzeugen können um zu überleben
dann ist die Antwort
ja
wir sind jetzt in einem
energieeffizienten Haus das wir umgebaut
haben das allein unser
haushaltsverbrauch doppelt so hoch ist
wie der des
Durchschnittsamerikaners das hat mich
wachgüttelt ich kann gar nicht zählen
wie viele Reisen nicht aus
geschäftlichen Gründen um die Welt
gemacht
habe und zwei internationale Reisen
entsprechen dem Energieverbrauch eines
Jahres in meinem
Haus das hat mich wirklich zum
Nachdenken über das b das hat mich dazu
gebracht darüber nachzudenken was ich
esse eine weitere Überraschung für viele
Menschen ist wie viel Energie wir für
Lebensmittel
verbrauchen in den USA verbrauchen wir
jährlich 100 Quadrillionen BTU an
Energie BTU ist eine britische
Wärmeeinheit und entspricht etwa dem
Energiegehalt eines Streichholzes wir
verbrauchen also 100 Milliarden
Millionen Streichhölzer pro Jahr
10 Quadrillionen BTU sind für das
lebensmittelsystem eines dieser
Quadrillionen steckt in den
Lebensmitteln selbst jedes Jahr nehmen
330 Millionen Amerikaner ein Vierfaches
an Nahrungsenergie in ihren Körper auf
die anderen neu Quads entfallen auf den
Rest des lebensmittelsystems Düngemittel
Pestizide Diesel für die Traktoren die
Kühlung Trocknung der Ernte Lagerhäuser
Transport und die Energie für das Kochen
zu
Hause oder sind nur für die Kühlkette
vom kühllastwagen bis zu den
Kühlschränken bei uns zu
Hause die USA verbrauchen hierfür mehr
Energie als ganze Länder wie die Schweiz
und Schweden zusammen in einem
Jahr die Energie die in den genießbaren
Lebensmitteln steckt die wir wegwerfen
reicht aus um ganze Länder zu versorgen
wir werfen etwa ein Viertel bis die
Hälfte unserer Lebensmittel weg
also Michael wir sind von Wasser umgeben
wie ist die Beziehung zwischen Wasser
und
Energie zum einen verwenden wir eine
Menge Wasser für die Energiegewinnung um
Kraftwerke zu kühlen um Biokraftstoffe
zu bewässern wir verwenden Wasser für
die Öl und Gasförderung für die
Dampferzeugung in Raffinerien in der
energieversorgungskette ist Wasser in
jedem Schritt enthalten unser Brunnen
ist trocken tot ja das ist tot hier war
das Wasser es ging bis
hierhin das ist keine Fantasy Apokalypse
Filmlandschaft es ist jetzt und es ist
real das Netz könnte belastet werden
wenn es kein Wasser zum Kühlen gibt
zumindest bei den meisten Kraftwerken
die mit Wärme Arbeiten moderne Formen
wie Solarzellen und Windturbinen
brauchen keine
Wasserkühlung wie lange ist die
durchschnittliche Lebensdauer von
Solarpanelen 20 Jahre 20 25 25
vielleicht 30 die Leute sagen also na ja
man braucht 7 Jahre Energie um dieses
Paneel zu produzieren aber dann bekommt
man 18 Jahre Energie umsonst also hat
man gespart selbst dann bekommt man 18
Jahre Energie umsonst ja also ich und
John public wir sagen hey ich möchte
Geld in deine Solarfarm stecken nein
nicht bevor sich die Regierung einmischt
und uns in eine paripos gegenüber
fossilen Brennstoffen
bringt ich habe viele Freunde die in der
Branche der erneuerbaren Energien
arbeiten und da gibt es ein wirklich
großes Problem man hat den
stromabnahmevertrag alle Genehmigungen
sogar
verbundvereinbarungen aber dann
verzögern die Netzbetreiber die
inbriebnahme was ist da
los na ja wer hat Zugang zuur
Infrastruktur die Demokratisierung der
Infrastruktur ist eine Möglichkeit sie
zu öffnen damit mehr Lösungen entwickelt
werden können das haben wir in den 80er
Jahren bei der Telekommunikation mit
AT&T gemacht die mussten ihre
Infrastruktur für andere Unternehmen
öffnen deshalb gibt es jetzt so viele
Telefongesellschaften das gleiche könnte
mit der Demokratisierung der
elektrischen Infrastruktur passieren
dann gäbe es mehr Wind und Solarenergie
und wir hätten mehr Technologien auf dem
Weg dorthin dafür sind langfristige
Planung und stabile Regierungen wirklich
wichtig was ich so höre ist dass es kein
technologisches Problem ist es ist kein
technisches problemin es ist ein
finanztechnisches
Problem
Energiearmut
Nahrungsmittelknappheit
Einkommensungleichheit es liegt also
jetzt an uns die Politik zu gestalten
die helfen wird diese Kluft zu
überbrücken als die USA 199 in den Krieg
zogen sammelten die Menschen Blechdosen
und Aluminium Frauen hörten auf
Nylonstrümpfe zu kaufen alles wurde für
diesen Kriegseinsatz getan aber der
Krieg war da er war direkt vor unserer
Nase
junge Männer wurden eingezogen und nach
Übersee geschickt es gab viele Tote in
der Heimat das ist etwas anderes es
erfordert die gleiche Art von
Umstrukturierung oder
Engagement warum haben Sie nicht mich
gefragt ich hätte doch was tun
[Musik]
können das war damals und das ist heute
schauen Sie sich unser neues los an das
lösungslos suchen Sie etwas das einfach
ist und in ihrer Preisklasse liegt
schauen Sie sich unsere gebrauchten
Lösungen an wie das Wechseln einer
Glühbirne oder zur Arbeit zu laufen oder
unsere mittleren Angebote wie
regenerative Landwirtschaft oder ein
Preis für Kohlenstoff oder lassen Sie
sich von einer Vielzahl brandneuer
Lösungen begeistern wie z.B die
Auslagerung des klimarisikos aus dem
Derivatemarkt oder die Millionen
meilenbatterie die bald auf den Markt
kommt hören Sie einfach auf einen
unserer zufriedenen Kunden
Michael sie sind jetzt für die
Energiepolitik der USA zuständig und
haben freie Hand wie würden Sie den
Übergang
Gestalten aus Gründen der nationalen
Sicherheit des Umweltschutzes und aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen müssen wir
unser Netz verbessern und ausbauen
vielleicht sogar unter Nutzung der
Interstate Highways wir haben bereits
die Rechte und legen Leitungen dann wird
es sich ausdehnen und bis zu den
sonnigen windigen Gebieten reichen und
an die stätischen Gebiete
angeschlossen sobald wir das Netz haben
können wir anschließen was wir wollen
aber wir müssen einen Preis für die
Verschmutzung festlegen dann nehmen wir
das Geld um die Müllbeseitigung zu
bezahlen die USA Blasen jedes Jahr 6
Milliarden Tonnen CO2 in die Atmosphäre
wenn wir 30 $ pro Tonne zahlen um sie zu
entfernen macht das 180 Milliarden
Dollar pro Jahr das ist weniger als das
was wir allein für die Müllbeseitigung
in den Städten ausgeben warum nicht noch
ein paar hundert Milliarden für die
Beseitigung des Mülls in der Atmosphäre
ausgeben wir sollten das CO2 in den
Boden
einbringen die Landwirte dafür bezahlen
dass sie CO2 aus der Atmosphäre in den
Boden einbringen
ja wir brauchen mehr von dieser
nationalen
sicherheitsmentalität wenn man eine Bild
to last Strategie hat dann sollte man
sich ansehen was in diesen längeren
Zeiträumen passiert das ist absolut
entscheidend wir werden alle
Energieformen und alle Menschen brauchen
um diesen Übergang zu
bewältigen anderenfalls glaube ich nicht
dass wir wirklich eine Chance
[Musik]
haben ich versuche dieses Auto
loszuwerden aber es ist wie mit dem
Rauchen aufzuhören verstehen sie es ist
nicht einfach man hat sich so sehr an
bestimmte Dinge gewöhnt dass es sehr
schwierig
ist haben dem Ökosystem viel Schlimmes
angetan aber sie haben es nicht so
zerstört wie wir es
könnten der Katastrophenschutz schätzt
dass man für jeden Dollar der für die
Gefahrenabwehr ausgegeben wird
an Kosten für die Wiederherstellung nach
einer Katastrophe spart wir geben das
Geld also bereits aus es gibt das Gefühl
dass es vielleicht zu teuer ist sich auf
den Klimawandel vorzubereiten aber wir
geben das Geld bereits aus wir geben es
nach jeder Katastrophe aus
wissen Sie als ich aufgewachsen bin gab
es die Wehrpflicht jeder dachte er sei
dem Land verpflichtet wenn man auf ein
landgr College ging wurde man
eingezogen heute ist das anders das
Vertrauen in die Regierung ist weg die
Verpflichtung gegenüber der Regierung
ist verschwunden wenn wir nur etwas von
diesem Geist des Patriotismus nehmen und
in wieder aufbauen könnten um etwas für
die Umwelt zu
tun dieses ganze Ding ist aus
Kohlenstoff gebaut der aus der
Atmosphäre
[Musik]
kommt wir brauchen 100.000 junge Leute
die einen Teil ihres Sommers opfern um
sich zu formieren und wirklich daran zu
arbeiten wir könnten diese pinienkäfer
die den Wald zerstören bekämpfen wir
könnten neue Bäume pflanzen aber das
sollte nicht nur gegen Bezahlung
geschehen sondern auch aus der
Verpflichtung jedes Bürgers heraus sich
um das Land zu kümmern das ist es was
ich gerne sehen würde das klingt als
wollten sie eine ganze Generation von
Menschen dafür begeistern das klingt wie
etwas das alte Männer sagen
würden das hat mich dazu gebracht ihr zu
Liebe mehr zu kämpfen die Verwandlung
ist aufregend weil wir nicht nur darüber
nachdenken sollten Dinge zu verlieren
die wir immer gewollt
sondern auch über das Loslassen von
Dingen von denen wir vielleicht nicht
profitieren wir können verlieren um uns
in etwas anderes zu verwandeln wir sind
nicht so zuversichtlich dass alles gut
wird aber wir finden Möglichkeiten dass
ich die Dinge auf wirklich dramatische
Weise
verändern die Geschichte lehrt uns dass
es viele verschiedene Zivilisationen und
unterschiedliche Wirtschaftssysteme und
Handelsformen gibt daher war das
Mittelalter einfach eineere Art von
Wirtschaft sicher man passte sich an den
Mangel an Ressourcen an aber das führte
auch zu einer neuen Art zu denken und
das Leben
anzugehen wir versuchen die Arten von
Nutzpflanzen die wir anbauen wollen zu
diversifizieren und auch mit
naturschutzprogrammen zusammenzuarbeiten
um Arten und Lebensräume zu erhalten und
der Natur ihren Lauf zu lassen damit die
Arten zurückkehren die wir brauchen und
die die Nutzpflanzen brauchen um Produk
zu
sein wir wollen kein Hurricane oder
Tropensturm sie sind schon vorbereitet
die Ernte ist im Gange sie wollen
weitermachen und fertig werden die
Menschen wollen wissen woher ihr Essen
kommt irgendwann wollen die Leute
vielleicht auch wissen wo ihr bker wohnt
und wer er ist und ob ich eine Beziehung
zu ihm habe wenn ich Geld brauche um
etwas zu reparieren kann ich vielleicht
jemanden finden der mir
hilft
ich meine es geht nicht darum dass die
Regierung den Banken vorschreibt was sie
zu tun haben oder uns sagt was wir tun
können es gibt noch viele
Möglichkeiten wir sollten kleinere
Banken haben sie aufspalten damit sie
nicht zu groß zum Scheitern werden wenn
sie Fehler machen sollten Sie scheitern
ohne eine totale Systemkrise auszulösen
und was wahrscheinlich auch getan werden
muss ist die Einführung von Regeln die
es dem Finanzsektor unmöglich machen
innerhalb des Finanzsektors selbst so
viele zusätzliche Sch
wir müssen diese Unvollkommenheit des
Marktes irgendwie
korrigieren wenn Sie ein Derivat haben
wollen wenn Sie Ihr Risiko absichern
wollen gut aber sie müssen dem zugrunde
liegenden Vermögenswert ausgesetzt
sein ich erinnere mich dass ich nach
einer großen Überschwemmung in Florida
fernsah und sie Interviewten diesen Mann
und er sagte mein Vater hat zweimal
wieder aufgebaut mein Großvater hat
zweimal wieder aufgebaut und ich werde
es wieder tun und der Reporter drehte
sich zur Kamera und sagte das ist der
amerikanische weg ich dachte der
Reporter sollte sagen das ist dumm man
kann das nicht immer wieder machen das
ist die Definition von
irresinn es ist im Grunde das Vertrauen
in die Geldverwaltung und das Vertrauen
in die zukünftige Produktivität eines
Landes dass uns Vertrauen in die Währung
gibt und nicht die Vorstellung dass die
Zentralbank ein paar Goldbarren
versteckt es gibt einen Punkt des
Widerstands an dem die Regierungen
keinen Zugang zu Kapital haben um das
Problem zu
[Musik]
lösen die Befürchtung ist wenn wir das
System nicht mehr retten können dann
stürzen wir ab mit riesigen
Nebenwirkungen die Hoffnung und das
klingt ein bisschen zynisch aber die
Hoffnung ist dass wir unser System
wahrscheinlich erst nach einem Crash neu
ordnen können ich glaube die Geschichte
der Menschheit zeigt dass wir die Art
und Weise wie wir leben und uns
organisieren ohne einen solchen Crash
nicht wirklich grundlegend verändern
können niemand will das und ich bin die
letzte die das will wenn ich an die 30er
Jahre denke und ich bin Deutsche wenn
man überlegt welche Auswirkungen eine
Krise haben kann wissen wir einfach
nicht wie wir am anderen Ende des
Tunnels wieder herauskommen werden ohne
diese Krise sehe ich einfach nicht genug
politischen Einfluss um die Art wie wir
unser Finanzsystem organisieren
grundlegen zu
ändern wenn der Klimawandel eintritt
wird es echte Probleme geben und es wird
echte wie Sie sagten echte Knappheiten
geben und es werden echte Migranten
kommen und es wird und dann werden wir
wirklich pleite sein weil es nach dem
Zusammenbruch der umgekehrten Pyramide
sein wird und dann ist es so als würden
wir Somalia bitten den Klimawandel zu
bekämpfen deine Kritik ist also dass wir
uns der Realität nicht stellen und uns
nicht
anpassen das stimmt meine Antwort darauf
ist dass ich immer noch an die
Demokratie glaube ich glaube dass wir es
als Volk schaffen können als
Gesellschaft und ich glaube wir können
die Institutionen der USA die diesem
Land über 200 Jahre lang sehr gut
gedient haben nehmen und ins 21
Jahrhundert führen und die Menschheit
voranbringen das ist eine Glaubensfrage
aber es ist der Glaube der zum Handeln
motiviert wir haben fast alle Werkzeuge
alle finanziellen Ressourcen und
Institutionen die dieses Problem lösen
können es ist die Art von
Herausforderung die die Menschheit auf
eine Weise zusammenbringen könnte wie
sie noch nie zuvor zusammengebracht
wurde ich wünschte es gäbe mehr
Gespräche mehr Leute auf beiden Seiten
die miteinander reden denn jeder von dem
wir denken dass er auf der Gegenseite
ist ist genauso recht schaffen wir
sollten zusammenkommen um zu sehen wenn
man sich mit solchen Leuten trifft
stellt man fest dass die
Meinungsverschiedenheiten eigentlich
ziemlich klein sind ja das meine ich die
meisten Leute sind sich zu 95% einig
aber es gibt Kräfte die diese
Meinungsverschiedenheiten verschärfen
und populär machen
wollen das ist eine Frage der
menschlichen Natur was verkauft sich
also sag mir waskau
worauf achtest du wenn es um dich herum
passiert man muss Leute finden die
Konflikt Konflikt Konflikt das ist es
diese Art von Dialog zwischen Vater und
Sohn zu schaffen wissen sie das ist mein
Kind und so sie müssen ja einige wilde
Unterhaltungen
führen das regt mich auf nein die der
demok ich bin komplett anderer Meinung
kitalism nein dem stimme ich nicht
zu
[Musik]